so uh man crazy day we were talking
about this guy Daniel Perry the other
day and he got convicted if you don't
know who he is he's the guy who was
driving Uber in Austin wearing shorts
flip-flops and a t-shirt when far left
extremists surrounded his car one with
an AK-47 pointed at him and then he
fired in self-defense they opened fire
on him he fled called the police and
they claimed he attempted to he wanted
to murder these people and so he was
convicted right now many prominent
personalities are calling on Greg Abbott
of Texas to Pardon this man he was
convicted in in Texas in Austin and I
got to tell you guys I keep having
people you know they had said to me over
and over again before we relocated from
New Jersey they're like you got to go to
Texas man you got to go to Texas
everyone's going to Austin and I was
like Austin is like the California of
Texas why would I go there why would I
want to be in Texas in general and well
there's a fair point it was a purple
State now it's turning red because
people moved there so I accept that but
at the same time look what they're doing
to people table we're going to go over
the story this one this one's kind of
crazy and then to get in the details
about what's going on at the same time
this guy's going to jail you have Riley
Gaines the swimmer who's speaking out
about men competing in women's sports
being physically attacked forced into
into hiding in at the University of
Kentucky and these conversations need to
happen because what is the left doing
they're holding up seven fingers as they
storm the capital of Tennessee claiming
that the mass murderer in Nashville is a
victim that's their narrative and
they'll keep playing it yet the man who
was defending himself while just wearing
t-shirt and shorts in his car was it was
had a gun point at him he is the bad guy
so we're going to talk about all of that
before we get started my friends head
over to timcast.com
become a member by clicking join us
right there on the left and you'll get
access to members only uncensored shows
Monday through Thursday but also our
Discord Community when you sign up you
can get access to various chat rooms
where you can hang out with other
like-minded individuals and the
community building thing is a big
component of what we're trying to get
done if you're a member for at least six
months or you sign up at the 25 level
you'll get access to the VIP chat room
which allows you to submit questions to
call into our after shows Monday through
Thursday so definitely check that out
don't forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends we got a couple people
join us tonight we've got from Oasis oan
right we got Karen McKinney thank you
for having me I'm so excited to be here
absolutely who are you what do you do so
my name is Cara McKinney I host Tipping
Point on one America news I've been
doing that for about three years started
with the company about six years ago
writing and producing in The Newsroom so
it's been a fun Journey up and up to
wherever we go next so right on so
you've been tracking a lot of news you
know a bit about what's going on Everest
yeah the stuff we're talking about today
you know ever since I was little I kind
of started like
um debating teachers that was my biggest
thing so I kind of like that I I find it
fun I kind of thrive in that right on
cool well we got a lot to talk about and
then we also got in the uh the reserve
chair we got Clint he's back
Clint Russell liberty lockdown as well
as Tower gang co-host maybe one day soon
a Tim Cass employee will find out
um poker with the boys poking with the
boys baby let's go uh Tim and I played
today and we wiped the floor with
everybody so I feel like we're we're on
a gun that's right we were we were doing
a little test run and uh wiped the floor
with everybody as per usual you know and
so uh yeah that's the plan we're getting
everything built for uh poker with the
boys so so Clint's here we'll have him
on the show while he's here and then uh
we got Hannah Claire hanging out hi I'm
Hannah Claire I'm a current timcast
employee I'm a writer for timcast.com
I'm Ian cross and some days are dark and
sometimes we talk about the dark
spinning depth of the black hole sorry
that we're surrounding but listen
sometimes you get a white pill and that
was today when Vivek Vivek Vivek Rama
Swami yeah with the culture War podcast
with Tim if you haven't seen yet it's on
the Tim pool Channel man they went for
two hours Vivek is running for president
the Republican party and the guy has
Solutions it really impressive yeah I
I'll stress that too youtube.com timcast
or on Apple and Spotify the culture War
podcast Vivek really is one of the I I
look I I was honest I said I think I'll
vote for you in the primary Donald Trump
will win and I'll vote for Trump in the
general and he's like okay we'll see
we'll see but in terms of knowing what's
going on having Solutions and actually
I mean he was talking about defunding
the FBI about firing most of the Federal
Reserve really gutting these things
foreign policy stuff he went all at it
so but brilliant dude exceptionally and
you really got to see him to know like
it's worth watching just understand your
words won't do them Justice you got to
see the to to understand he made this
point as we were talking about
algorithmic manipulation he said
something like people what do you say he
said people thought the AI monster was
gonna be a robot with laser eyes but
it's not it's Dylan Mulvaney it's people
who are manipulated by the algorithms
into becoming things that are out of
sync or or disruptive to society well
let us keep each other in check and not
become the disruptive force uh that we
so fear uh yeah we also have Kellen over
here what's happening Fridays are the
best days what's up guys it's Kellen
let's get this thing started all right
here's the first story from the Daily
Mail Army Sergeant is convicted of
murdering black lives matter protester
by shooting him dead during July 2020
riots in Wake of George Floyd murder
Daniel Perry 37 a 37 year old Uber
driver an army Sergeant was driving
through downtown Austin on the night of
July 25th 2020 he ended up in the middle
of a BLM March and in an altercation
with protester Garrett Foster full stop
that's not what happened Daily Mail is
wrong Foster just walked up to his car
with a rifle pointed it at him and then
this guy fired back that's that's it he
didn't like yell at him or anything
nobody was yelling Perry shot Foster
dead claimed it was self-defense but on
Friday jury found him guilty of
murdering Fosters as a few key details
which need to be mentioned first I will
say there is a widespread push from tons
of conservative personalities calling on
Greg Abbott to Pardon this man and I
agree not like this guy look this guy
certainly said some things that I find
questionable in in the past but that is
no bearing on the fact that he's an Uber
driver he's wearing shorts and a t-shirt
and flip-flops and a guy wearing a vest
with a rifle and a mask marching with
BLM points a gun at him and then he
fires in self-defense if they were gonna
say you know reckless endangerment or
something I'd roll my eyes and be like
well you know they're getting them
whatever but murder and life in prison
that's what they're going for
they say he was driving through found
himself in the midst of a protest blah
blah blah blah blah let me scroll down
defense lawyers said that Foster raised
his AK-47 at Perry and that Perry fired
in self-defense Witnesses have said
during the trial that Foster never
raised his rifle at Perry well of course
the Witnesses are BLM protesters of
course they are likely to lie
a jury found him guilty in their closing
arguments they insisted he had no choice
but to shoot Foster five times as he
approached Perry's car with an AK-47
prosecutors said Perry had plenty of
choices including driving away full stop
how many stories have we heard where
people who drove away were accused of
hit and run or something because people
are banging on their car so did he and
they opened fire on him I don't care if
you were rioting and you're carrying
weapons and you approached someone and
they and and they're and they they panic
because you're pointing weapon at him
sorry and of course I just don't believe
that the the BLM people however
they say Perry also said that in Texas
you could get away with shooting them
they mentioned his social media posts
that's probably what got him you should
not say that stuff Perry's phone showed
he was texting woman shortly before the
encounter with Foster the woman he
wanted to meet up with send him a text
asking for money this is an age-old
story about a man who couldn't keep his
anger under control it's not about
police it's not about protest Marchers
it is there's video I'm I'm not going to
play the video but look people have a
right to keep in bear arms people have a
right to March down the street with
those weapons you don't have a right to
be part of a group that is that has
committed several acts of terrorism over
the past over the previous days and then
surround someone's vehicle while
pointing a rifle at them that's just
that you've crossed the line and so my
response to all this is it's a horrible
story I wish it didn't happen it sucks
but how is putting this guy in prison
going to solve anything
uh it's a sensitive it's a sensitive
story and I don't have a lot of data on
this I really what it comes down to was
this guy pointing the gun at him or not
and we only have witness testimony
because if he has the gun and it's like
at an angle right past pointing right
past the guy and he's moving towards the
guy it could give the illusion that he's
gonna that he's pointing towards him but
and and I don't know where where how far
away were the witnesses
how do you how do you get him on murder
because of the idea that he premeditated
it or had intent with that post on
social media and so and so the let me
read this protesters didn't know
anything about Perry when they attacked
the car and boxed it in said Doug
O'Connell who was defense defending
Perry O'Connell argued that Foster was
dressed for battle at the protest
including wearing a neoprene vest
carrying an AK-47 a club and a knife
Perry was wearing a t-shirt shorts and
flip-flops Garrett Foster is dressed for
war Daniel Perry is dressed for the
beach
murder means intent if they want to say
reckless endangerment or negligent
homicide I'd be sitting here we'd be
arguing the legal merits no they they
convicted him for intentionally going to
this guy and killing him
I thought and I think because as you're
bringing up with the social media post
and they were trying to say see aha he
wanted this chance to do what he did I
think what it actually shows is his
mindset is like oh my gosh look how
scary these you know these rioters are
these looters are you know the different
social media posts that he had so when
he turns the corner and I think during
the trial it came out that there was
evidence that his car was slowing
because all the witnesses to your point
earlier about the witnesses saying well
he didn't point the gun well the
witnesses also said that he sped up into
them and I think they said oh we just
heard tires screeching and this and that
but then I think the evidence of the
trial show that his car was decelerating
correct decelerated to a quadriplegic
woman exactly use the crosswalk so there
are lines into it yeah so he turns into
and he's like oh my gosh and his mindset
is I've been following this for months
now how scary I don't want to be the
next guy to die oh my gosh a gun's in my
face now I think that more accurately
describes why he has those past social
media posts rather rather than what the
you know prosecutors are trying to say
is that oh he's a bad man looking for a
fight and other Witnesses have testified
that they had called the cops saying
this group is carrying guns we've asked
them to leave we can't do anything I
mean all the outlets are describing as
like they were marching everything's
fine but like put yourself back into
this summer of 2020. it was an extremely
turbulent and violent times in major
cities Across America and people who
were sort of caught in the crosshairs
residents who lived in the area just had
to wait and hope that nothing that fatal
would happen and fortunately in this
case it did and I wonder if his defense
was smart enough to bring up this story
from Deseret police arrest two after man
shot during Provo protest that's right
BLM ran up to a truck for no reason
literally none this guy wasn't this
wasn't a truck driver chasing anybody
down it was a guy driving on the street
BLM extremists ran up and shot the guy
in his car June 30th 2020. and they say
two people who are arrested Tuesday
night in connection with the shooting of
a motorist about one month later
this army Sergeant was driving down the
street in Austin when he was approached
by a guy with a gun and shot back and
that context I think is extremely
important for the jury to understand the
this faction of individuals their
ideology they have been committing acts
of Terror they have been killing people
and only a couple weeks ago walked up to
a motorist and shot him and here I am in
my car is what I'd say and they were
walking up to me and I said here we go
again that's the gun he points it at me
but you know what it doesn't matter
because they're in Austin
and I I think anybody I I find it
laughable that people are like you go to
move to Austin man and I was like no no
you don't you do not want to live in
these places you will go to prison when
they try to kill you and you try to
defend yourself yeah and it seems so
obvious that it was self-defense in this
particular instance but what I would
like to know is there's been other
pretty egregious police killings of
litany of minorities as well as white
people since the Biden Administration
came to power you have not heard from
black lives matter in terms of protests
and riots and things like that and and
what that tells me is that it was it was
catalyzed somehow and we still don't
have answers as to how that came to pass
and I would like to know
you mean the Riots of 2020 yeah the
whole summer man it was crazy it was
like three it was basically 100 days of
just misery and insanity and and I just
don't buy the organic nature of that and
for the life of me I wish oan or some
you know some organization that's
actually interested in getting to the
truth would would dig into that because
it seems like there's a story there and
I don't know what it is
oh uh go ahead oh you're gonna be much
more interesting than me
I was just going to say on one point yes
it kind of reads like you know color
revolutions and stuff where these big
muddied interests that they go out there
and they're able to kind of fund and
they can kind of put money into it they
can kind of get people amped up and out
there on the streets I think Foster was
on the streets I think
yeah exactly so he kind of was like a
full-time protester Rider at that point
one thing that I do think is interesting
to perhaps bring up here is that I know
he was I know I think reporting says he
was a Boogaloo boy right the the
fostering so I know the big gun control
culture right however he was rolling
with BLM and of course we saw a lot of
that kind of you know mix in the summer
of 2020 with the riots but it's
interesting to me because with BLM and
other left-wing groups one of their
Hallmarks is pushing for gun control
yeah it's interesting that it's only
specific groups it's only like law
abiding regular Americans that they want
gun control for you see the Chas for
example antifa and other Related Group
Johns Brown's clubs the rest it's
interesting that when they set up their
little chats what did they first do they
erected a border they patrolled that
border with armed guards and they
deported anyone they didn't like from
the area and you've seen that over and
over and over with these groups so when
they say gun control they don't really
mean gun control they just want to be
the ones with the guns and the people
they don't like not having the guns in
this case Foster and friends having guns
and the um Perry and his friends not
having guns boom and then we saw in
Wisconsin when BLM protesters cheered
and clapped as a man was arrested in his
own home
I thought they were supposed to be
against the cops no no when the police
come and arrest you they are clapping
for it that's where we're going that's
where we are
yeah disturbing so what are the odds you
think that uh Abbott steps up and does
something about this I think it's
actually pretty high you know because
I'm I I look
this is violent extremists they've
killed other people before there's 20
plus deaths there's there's 19 plus
deaths directly tied to the protest and
an estimated 32 in the periphery of of
the riots I shouldn't say protest riots
this guy in his shorts and t-shirt
convicted of murder something's wrong
here uh Abbott needs to just pardon yeah
well let me let me say one quick thing
in defense of the Boogaloo boys which
will be very unpopular but uh many of
them are Libertarians and many of them
are hard 2A guys and many of them were
out there just to defend the protesters
from the police however if you're going
to approach someone and you're
protesting in the middle of the street
and you have a vehicle that is now
stopped and surrounded and you approach
them with an AK-47 or whatever sort of
assault right well I don't even want to
say assault rifle the scary looking guns
um not a good idea it's not just that
the Boogaloo boys have uh uh been
praised for for they're not they're not
directly anti for BLM no they're not but
if you are Marching with antifa and BLM
There's no distinction sorry these
people have firebombed buildings they
have killed people uh Michael reinel in
Portland with a BLM communist tattoo on
his neck shot Aaron Danielson twice in
the chest and then you're like you know
what I'm gonna march with these people
it's like well with a with a rifle and
you pointed at someone and people are
pointing on the chat there's a video of
him holding the weapon at high ready
he's got the gun ready to go if a guy
approaches you high ready with a rifle
at high ready man in the middle of a a
riot and you're stuck and you can't move
you've got to assume the worst what
choice I'm not trying to incite stuff
but like what what are you supposed to
do in that situation you have to protect
yourself yeah you can either just put
your hands down and stick your chest out
right out of the tip of his gun maybe
but like what's the other choice here no
consider the game consider the options
exactly you have to hit the guess drive
through in which case you're going to
get an attempted homicide charge or you
fire in which case you're charged with
murder and apparently convicted or you
just cross your fingers and hope that
the dude's not gonna fire him this is
beyond just happening to somebody in a
vehicle with BLM we saw the the the the
the
um parking garage attendant in New York
right who a guy literally shot him twice
fighting for his life this man wrestles
The Gun away and then shoots the
would-be murderer and then he wakes up
being criminally charged attempted
murder in a hospital after nearly dying
and he's crying he was crying in bed
saying I don't understand this is a
nightmare what's happening why are they
doing this to me because they're evil
people they are evil there's no question
I'm sorry Ian it is a fact if a man is
on his death bed after being shot twice
and he's crying saying why why why God
it's because Bragg is an evil person and
the only reason he backed up that
prosecution is because people who are
good stood up and said don't you try it
and then he backed I said no okay okay
we're gonna stop do you think Muslim is
evil in general well it's the to a
certain degree but let me make this
point what's happening to this guy
Daniel Perry
I was surprised to find out the trial
was going on how did we not know about
this how is this story which is similar
to Kyle Rittenhouse different many ways
completely just under arms there's no
video no video there is video is it good
video is it enough to know what's going
on no I mean from what I've read
everyone is saying it's not super clear
even the police body cam footage
responding to the incident is like a
little ambiguous I mean the defense
called uh their own ballistics expert to
try and analyze the video and I think
that's one of the reasons that uh Kyle
Rittenhouse was able to not get lost in
sort of the immediate uh media backlash
that would have inevitably followed him
because so many people could point to
this video and say look at it like you
can't spin this it's pretty obvious what
happened here yeah and look at this
story from Deseret
how are we supposed to live in a country
where you hear the news about BLM for no
reason shooting a motorist who I believe
I believe was a woman you can see it and
people are mentioning in the chat
and then
what do you do you know what look man
you want to live in Austin fine at a
certain point I've got I'm I'm getting
to the point where I'm going to be like
oh did another person get convicted of
murder for for trying to save their own
life
no sympathy yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry
dudes look
I'm not going to say it's not I'm not
going to say it's easy for a lot of
people to get out of cities very very
hard very very difficult but
I'm just at the point where I'm like I
mean how many it's three years on three
years since the summer of love and I've
been saying even two years before that
you need to get out of these cities they
will do this to you they will arrest you
for what BLM does yeah if there's a
Democrat D.A you're in trouble and there
are people who are still like I'll be
fine I'll keep my head down it's like
okay when that happens and they do come
and arrest you don't expect me to to
offer any assistance do you think one of
the biggest things is because those who
are on
I guess right libertarian various
assorted groups is that we kind of don't
like you know state power so much so
it's more like elections come by we're
not as into it as say someone who is one
of the left ideological you know groups
so when local elections come around
we're not as mobilized and we're not as
interested like you said with this uh
this this trial a lot of people weren't
as you know paying attention to it as
much so I think that happens a lot
because even if you get out of cities
you could be in a smaller town where you
know everyone seems to be kind of maybe
more conservative and you think wow I
feel really safe here everyone supports
law enforcement and then before you know
it you didn't pay attention to your
local elections and Eric how come this
da is letting everyone out how come my
you know an on and on but the the issue
is it's not bad enough and so there is
one simple reality if you are holding on
to a skillet and it burns your hand you
will let go
the issue is the damage and destruction
that is occurring in cities is not is
not escalating to a point just yet where
people are going to drop the pan I.E get
out now let me give you analogy right
you grab a you put on your oven mitts
and you grab a a tray of fudge brownies
from the oven
and you're holding on to it and you're
trying to figure out where to put the
brownies down and you can feel the heat
is making its way through those mitts
what happens if you don't put it down
right now
eventually the mitts can't stop the heat
it burns your hand you drop the pan
maybe it's Pyrex it shadows in the
ground and now there's a disaster Zone
when instead you could have been like
okay I gotta just set this down anywhere
I can set it down it's getting too hot
what's happening right now is we're at
that point people are still in these
cities and we can feel the heat but
they're going look the heat that I'm
feeling the pressure that I'm feeling in
the city does not reach a level where
I'm willing to experience hardship to
get out and I mean it hardship I'm not
saying it's easy it might be the most
difficult thing you've ever done but
trust me the people who have said to me
like you look man I got a house I can't
sell it I don't know how to move trust
me when bullets fly through your
daughter's window you will pack up and
leave and go sleep under a bridge or
something like that you will be like
okay that is too hot and so my point is
simply this
I'm not passing judgment I'm simply
saying I understand why people are not
going to leave their homes until the
bullets come through their windows but
you know what it's already happened to a
lot of people yep and so like that guy
in Wisconsin
sooner or later the cop will come to
your house they will search your home
they will charge you with whatever they
want because you pissed off some BLM
activist group because they know who you
are you watch this show and then you're
going to be like it's too late now yeah
now the the D.A is going to be like Mr
Smith don't leave the state and you're
going to be like now what do I do I got
to say real quick I'm reading Scott
Horton's pre-release of his new book
it's like 500 pages on the history
between uh Russia and Ukraine it's
incredible but the reason this
correlates and there is a correlation
he breaks down all of the color
revolutions that happened through the
Eastern Bloc Nations that were CIA
backed and I can't tell you how
reminiscent it was of living through
2020. and it just it strikes me as a
color Revolution I'm not saying it was
one but it felt a hell of a lot like one
when you read about them it's crazy it's
uncanny honestly what defines color
Revolution usually they're labeled by a
color so it'll be like the orange or the
rose or the red and things like that so
um but there's a Litany of them that
happen in Eastern Bloc Nations like the
break-off nations from Russia after the
fall of the USSR and
usually it deals with
electoral processes that are manipulated
in some fashion I'm not saying that's
what happened in America but that is
what the uh the CIA was I want to I want
to read this Council from uh Vision
storm he says Tim quote I'm not passing
judgment I'm just saying I have no
sympathies if you have no means to leave
your state no you completely
misunderstand perhaps intentionally
what I said is
for those who poo poo the idea and say
ah it's not that bad
that is to whom I'm saying I have no
sympathy if you've made this choice
right I'm also saying I understand for
some people it is too difficult to do
it's very difficult
and then I'm also pointing out that at a
certain point it doesn't matter how
difficult it is or the consequences you
will drop the tray the glass will
shatter and it will create a problem for
you this is what I'm saying if you are
holding something too hot
shattering glass on the ground is the
war is the last thing you want to happen
if you are living in a house and you are
like I have nowhere to put this thing
down the moment BLM shows up to your
house and sets of fire you will flee
your home with your kids having no idea
where you're going it's not a question
of your means to do so it is a fact if
your life your loved ones lives are
threatened you will go and sleep in a
tent in the woods before you let a
violent mob kill you I like that's it
like I don't think there's any human
being who's going to be like oh Auntie
fussier what are they yelling they want
to kill me I better just sit here
especially when you have kids you're
going to be like we're abandoning this
right so my view is it may be the most
difficult thing you have ever done
if it were me I don't want to give
anybody Financial advice if it weren't
me I would sell my house for whatever I
could get for it and move to move out to
the middle of nowhere that being said I
am fully aware of when we moved out of
Jersey it wasn't the most difficult
thing for us you know I I had a
successful YouTube channel I had money
that I'd saved up and so after saving
for about a year or two and I'm like I
think we better get out of here before
it's too late so then we bought property
out here in West Virginia got a little
tiny house somewhere and that's it
that's it and then we moved out here set
up the company in this in in what is now
the cast Castle which is the companies
you know I don't live here and that's
the point I understand for me it was it
was much easier and I moved much sooner
than most people but I do think sooner
or later
if you do nothing there will come a time
when BLM will come up to your house
they'll be armed for some reason or
another maybe you'll be at work and and
they're going to be or maybe this could
not get an American flag in the front of
your house they've already done this BLM
has already threatened people because
they had American flags on their houses
sooner or later in these cities it will
it will happen
you want to buy my my point to people is
if you could buy a lottery ticket
and if you won the lottery on it then
they would lock you that put you in
prison for life like that was the prize
the chances of it happening are very
very low but would you buy the ticket
anybody
no so the chances of BLM actually
showing up to your house in the
immediate future right now and
destroying it is a lottery ticket's
chance okay over time it's slowly
becoming more and more likely we are
seeing more and more of this several
years on now they're putting people in
prison after BLM attacked them look at
the cash app founder too in in San
Francisco exactly do you think there was
something to do that because that was 2
A.M I think he was doing a drug deal or
something no right now he was he was he
was that guy must have been worth a
billion dollars he's walking up drunk
what was it 2 A.M why was he outside at
2 A.M in San Francisco on a weekend yeah
everybody's out at 2 am in a week
drinking maybe he was in San Francisco
was a major urban area where he used to
live I mean he could be coming home he
was going to his house he was going to
his apartment wasn't he yeah he was like
he was at his apartment it wasn't a bad
area yeah and his family don't don't
take that and I don't know why it's it's
simple Bro 2 A.M in New York yes 2 A.M
bars close at four don't walk around in
cities at 2 A.M guys unless you
absolutely have to stick to the bright
lit streets walk fast like you're the
one that's dangerous
think about 360 as much as you can think
about what you're saying
that's all you got to live in a city man
it's dog eat dog or you get out because
or get out if you can it's insane
beautiful out in the open yeah it is
insane that we've gotten to the point
where it's like if you go out at 2 A.M
in a city you might die yeah that's not
and then here's the best part the person
who did it is going to get let go
yeah you can't trust that there'll be
any justification I think the video you
have to be conscious of that the water
is boiling right like true you may not
lose everything today but do you want to
be in the place most likely to be the
next epicenter of one of these rights of
course probably not and it is difficult
to leave but make it a priority like
this is something that you maybe need to
make a goal let's let's talk about the
story from timcast.com female swimmer
Riley Gaines assaulted by trans
activists while speaking on women's
rights this is proof that women need sex
protected spaces the video is crazy the
video is absolutely nuts let me let me
uh let me play this video for you
is there any uh I'll just I'll just full
size it
is there audio or what
there was one I saw oh you know what the
issue is there's a
oh wait there it is the issue is that I
haven't muted
nope still no audio wait it's still
muted
there we go and now it's on the wrong
Channel we're bad at this audio thing
you guys
[Applause]
foreign
I don't think uh
having been on the ground and actually
seen this stuff I don't think people
realize what it's like when a mob forms
and comes after you it is freaking crazy
but let me explain something
here's how it's going to go down
for you in your city
you are going to be at a grocery store
or something
or a restaurant
and someone's going to overhear you
talking to your friend saying something
like yo these BLM people are nuts
they're going crazy and there's going to
be some waitress or what person who
hears you they're going to find out who
you are they're going to see your name
and they're going to find out where you
work things like that happened 10 years
ago it it things like that have happened
five years ago
one day they're going to start posting
online they're going to attack you and
your company is going to be like I don't
know what it is you did or who you talk
to but we cannot have this heat so we're
gonna have to let you go I don't know
who you pissed off or why you're gonna
be like I didn't do anything I don't
know what's going on I'm like well look
man we don't want to be involved or
whatever is you believe and your
ideologies don't fit this company
they're gonna go to your house they're
going to protest your house because this
is what happened in Wisconsin does
anybody know why they went to that guy's
house and protested he was some random
local guy made no sense
here's what happens
the mob there is no individual who
decides we are going to storm into this
person's house and kill them what
happens is the mob is just moving
amorphously one person steps out in
front everyone steps out in One
Direction they go to the house and one
person goes up and starts knocking on
the door
as soon as that person goes on the porch
it's an invitation to the rest of the
mob to go on the porch the person
knocking then someone sneaks by and
tries to jiggle the handle someone sees
the handle jiggle and then they pop the
handle and push the door open another
person sees the door go open and then
they push their they stick their head
and look around another person sees that
person starts sticking their head in and
say I guess I'll go in too all of a
sudden now these people are walking into
your house all being egged on by each
other the snowflake doesn't blame itself
for the Avalanche this is how I've seen
all riots form
there will be a large group of people
one guy one antifa guide will take a
water bottle and just throw it straight
up in the air the moment that bottle
comes down then a bunch of people see
the splatter and then they start
throwing things too they're like oh
people are throwing things they throw
things
so one step at a time one person moves
an inch another person moves an inch
further and then before you know it
they've kicked your door in they're
rampaging through your house they're
smashing stuff and then once they go
into your room one guy wearing a mask
punches you in your bed and then someone
else sees it and all sudden they're
jumping up and down in your room
stomping on things and smashing things
there's kids there's videos of them no
but there's like 14 year olds listening
that are going to be having nightmares
man we got to be careful I know it's it
is true that you got to be safe you got
to take care of yourself but you can
yeah get out of cities because what I
just described there's actually a video
of right now where people are sitting at
a restaurant and a mob of people are
standing on top of the of the restaurant
tables kicking the patrons in the face
and stomping on them I'm not just
describing something out of the blue I'm
explaining videos that have happened and
the guy in his house when the mob showed
up that mob had set fire to a different
house in Wisconsin twice and so this guy
Brandis is a shotgun through the window
and then puts it down the police come
and arrest him oh and I think he's just
describing the the nature of kind of a
mob Dynamic not necessarily trying to
scare uh 14 year olds but I think that
this also goes on the inverse for the
people that are out there in the streets
that are protesting because the the
gentleman and the Boogaloo boys I forget
his name right now but the guy that had
the AKA or whatever it was
um you know if you're gonna put yourself
in that situation you're also putting
yourself in tremendous danger because if
you have if you're a member of the mob
and people are are all moving towards
you in a wave well then if someone's
armed and they fear for their lives you
don't know what might happen and maybe
that guy had no ill intentions maybe you
know as he's approaching the car maybe
he's genuinely trying to subdue or calm
the situation but you just don't know so
I I agree with Tim I mean if if I think
a really good litmus test is look at the
outflow population of your state from
2020 to 2021. if you had harsh lockdowns
you probably already had a net outflow
and those people are going to be the
people that vote in alignment with your
belief systems so it means that your
state is now so hard blue you're
probably never going to have political
power in that state again and this is
why I fled California well then one
thing that scares me with the Riley
Gaines video and how she was going to
schools and trying to speak and they're
like the mob was after her is the fact
that how many times did we grow up
hearing you know the idea that well you
know those are because college kids have
been doing this for many decades of
course however it seems like it's the
intensity and the frequency is only
getting worse however the idea was that
these kids will graduate they'll get out
into the real world and then the real
world will somehow make them normal
functioning adults but no we haven't
seen that because now we've seen these
kids will graduate and they will bring
that with them to their workplaces I
think the New York Times ran up peace
the other year I think it was last year
right that Millennials are now afraid or
older Millennials are afraid of genzirs
who are coming along because you might
be 38 39 thinking that you're you know
you're quite liberal and stuff yourself
you're more liberal than your parents
but now and you don't even know what's
coming exactly the 23 year old will kid
comes in and he thinks that you are a
microaggressor that you are XYZ and and
this is what Vivek ramaswamy said when I
interviewed him today for the culture
War podcast that a lot of people thought
the I forgot exactly explained it but
the AI monster was going to be a cyborg
with laser eyes but it's Dylan Mulvaney
it is these young people who have been
manipulated by the AI and it's not
intentional but it's turned them into
something out of sync with with with
human civilization with American
civilization
these people live in a world crafted by
social media algorithms they are driven
to do things that they think will be
perceived as popular they are
weak-willed individuals
and this is leading to people believing
in saying things adopting insane
behaviors and engaging in extremely
violent tactics and sometimes they end
up writing code to make the AI let me
ask right and makes it worse one thing
that that is supplemental to the AI
ideological Takeover in 2000 August of
2011 Barack Obama included in a
executive order that you would have
every single federal governmental
Department would Implement a Dei
Department within their institution so
that was the beginning of the end in
terms of having any and keeping in mind
the federal government is the number one
the largest employer in this country so
they were really like the first shot
across the bow in terms of including
diversity Equity inclusion hiring and
firing practices which is really the
woke takeover of the business World
naturally because so much of the
government's contracts are with actual
Private Industry but they also will now
in include uh demands that they also
have a Dei department so in a matter of
about 12 years you went from this
concept being almost unheard of to being
everywhere is it that the government is
not I assume they can't make private
companies start up a department but are
they just saying we're not going to be
funding it's not so actually because you
can include as a requirement in your
government contracts that you will only
do businesses business with just like
the the uh I think it was the OSHA
vaccine mandate they were saying if you
are doing business with a government uh
contractor well they're going to have to
have the Mandate as well because that's
where the money's coming from it's
taxpayer money so they can still put the
same sort of requirements it's not force
but it's saying we won't do business
with you if you don't have this they
can't literally storm your offices and
demand this one be the DI room but they
can't say we won't we won't give you
money and therefore you can't operate
you can't pay your employees you'll
close down if we are the main source of
income we're your biggest client then
you're stuck very coerced that's that's
a really great point that you bring up
because on my show I had a Firearms
expert kind a guest and so he would be
able to explain this better than I can
I'll try and like we reinforce or kind
of boil down what he was saying he's
from amaland John Crump so you know
shout out to Sean Crump but he was
saying with one of Biden's recent
executive orders mid-march how the idea
was because the the the the dod I think
it is because they work so much with
Firearms manufacturers that to put the
squeeze on regular you know law abiding
citizens who want to buy guns they'll
tell you know the gun manufacturer well
if you want our contract and look how
much money we can give you well then you
can't sell XYZ Bingo Firearms are
accessories to civilians and that's how
they get you so I think it's kind of
similar to what you were saying it's
social emotional learning is taking over
Academia and the education system
diversity Equity inclusion is taking
over Corporate America as well as
obviously governmental departments and
then you have ESG which is taking over
the highest levels of Finance those are
the three evil acronyms that are taking
over everything you spoke to the vet
today I'm sure he would agree do you
think that there's uh that the market
will correct itself it's very tough
because what you're competing with is a
is a printing press-backed
mechanism you have you have access to
not just the law setting but the setting
of interest rates plus the setting of of
uh you know monetary Supply I mean it's
that's a huge
essentially planned economy let me
explain CCP yeah no no no
let me explain it for you guys
this is the dawning of the age of
Aquarius
this is the new religion that will seek
to subvert Christianity it is the
religion of the water Bearer I remember
reading about this and watching
documentaries back in the day about how
first it was the age of the ram if you
guys have seen Zeitgeist you know what
I'm talking about and that's why the the
Jews would blow the ram horn the Ram's
Horn and then Christianity was the age
of Pisces which is why they use the
symbol of the fish I'm not saying I
think that's true but that's what was
said and then the question was what
would be the new religion to supplant
and subvert Christianity the religion of
the age of Aquarius well as we enter the
age of Aquarius we have a new religion
in this tweet David Rosado explains the
great awokening is a global phenomenon
no evidence it started in the U.S media
analysis of 98 million news articles
across 36 countries quantifies exception
state-controlled media from China Russia
Iran using wokeness terminology to
criticize and mock the West
and here we see in this image you can
see the rise of terminologies related to
transphobia homophobia transphobic
islamophobia every one of these
countries even the Congo experienced a
major spike in social justice rhetoric
the one thing that correlates social
media simply put when the AI is created
and shared it functions to serve human
emotion and anger gets the most shares
so treating people like victims to get
them angry got content to be shared The
Human Experience similar all of these
countries started to realize this is
what makes us money the human being who
wrote the article about Trump being
Hitler
did not think they were doing anything
wrong
but what happens is
100 writers each write 100 stories put
them on the Internet and then the
algorithm says yeah the one where Trump
is Hitler that guy gets a million hits
makes a bunch of money and then everyone
says that's what we should write here we
are welcome to the new religion and it's
true because it gets picked up it's kind
of like there's always a language of
power throughout all time there's the
language that everyone kind of speaks
back in the day it was actually it's
like the lingua Franca other you know
the heads of state of England wanting to
speak to the heads of state of Spain if
they couldn't speak until uh
intellectually between English or
Spanish they would use French as the
intermediary Latin was that at one point
nowadays it's speaking the language of
power speaking the however you want to
phrase it wokeism social justices and
whatever you want to call it and that is
for example what was it like Guatemala
or something a nation where to get like
twenty thousand dollars in a state Grant
from the U.S state Department they had
to accept I think some of the money had
to be used for like drag queens shows
and in a country that's more
conservative like Guatemala it's like
well why would they need that it's
because if they can speak the language
then the state is going to in this state
meaning the US in this case will reward
them greatly in a similar way that there
used to be actual fashion crimes
remember we kind of joke about the but
that was like a thing you know the the
Nouveau reach of the 1800s versus the uh
like the old money families and how
could they tell each other part oh you
don't know how to dress you didn't wear
the new fashion for the spring it sounds
kind of silly right but you see that in
today like the Zuckerberg types they'll
kind of dress down they don't want to be
as flashy with their clothes and stuff
because again it's signaling I'm on a
different level I may be rich you may be
rich but I'm a different level than you
so the money of philanthropy where you
can kind of remake the world in your own
image and you can you kind of use your
charity as like an investment basically
it's not like they're giving away their
money now they're poor it kind of comes
back to help them but again it's
speaking the language of power and as
you were saying Tim earlier like this is
kind of like this has proven to be
successful so this is the language of
power other countries around the world
if they want that U.S money they want
that U.S backing they don't want to
color revolution in their country
they're going to speak that language
even if they're populous is like we
don't want right but they're going to
speak that language and they're going to
push us saying you better speak it is
coming such a profound point and if you
have ever watched any of the pressers
that come out of the World economic
forum and you see all of the richest
people on the planet and they get up
there and they talk about how they're
all concerned about the poor and I'm
like you're not though you're not but
they use that language it's such that
it's such a great analysis I never even
considered it that that is really the
the language mechanism that traverses
language barriers now because if you're
talking about equity and inclusion well
then you're just one of us other big
groups that have a lot of money a lot
back and go oh that guy need to get in
contact with him he's in the same way
and the World Bank and the IMF backs wef
in this entire it's insane new religion
yeah it's the new religion yeah the age
of Aquarius when does it begin
well it depends on who you ask I think
March 20th 2021 I thought it was 22.50
2160. some people say it begins but it
depends on some people have speculating
that's what it's they were in it right
now or that were in there we're in the
cost between I think you're watching the
emergence as as basically the Catholic
church has done a lot of good in history
but it's also done some bad I think the
pedophilia that came out of that in like
the 90s and stuff annihilated people's
love for Christmas there's a new report
uh I think it was out of Maryland about
a scandal going back to the 60s so all
that stuff is bad and it crushed the old
religion it soured and now people do
need something to believe in it's it's
but this is not what's causing what
we're seeing here it's created The Voice
here's the scary thing
this is you said the dawn of the age of
Aquarius is 2160. this when I pulled it
up it says 2021 so already that we're in
it I had her in 2012 that it was coming
up in like 21.50 or something it may be
and what is it like every 2 500 years
every 20 2160 years on 2016. so think
about this at the beginning of the age
it wouldn't immediately be that everyone
is indoctrinated into a new religion it
would be that several hundred years into
that era the new religion dominates
dominates
so this could be as we watch
Christianity start to diminish and this
new psychotic cult take power wow 100
200 years this could be the domination
that is so dark that's what happens and
I think perhaps why so because I'm a
devout Catholic I'll just have to stand
up for my church and say that actually
pedophilia obviously it happens anywhere
and everywhere unfortunately and so
actually it was a lot less that happened
in the church than happens and say the
teaching profession or others the church
is actually has again so it happened on
a smaller scale than people say it just
you know
well the mistake culturally people go oh
the church but on a on a greater thing
um so talking about like the you know
different ages or whatever I think one
thing is what's happened in this nation
has happened uh in a way that has
happened in okay maybe let's rephrase
this so what's happening in our nation
because of some of the market forces
because the liberalism and other things
have eroded the networks that bind
people and make people know who they are
what do you hear today from all the
disaffected mobs the people who will
come up and want to you know scream and
yell and you know threaten you and stuff
these are people who don't know who they
are and you hear that a lot but you go
back 200 years people knew who they were
you know who are you son of John I'm a
farmer on this I'm that they knew who
exactly who they were I'm a Catholic I'm
a presbyterian I'm a this this or that
nowadays people don't know who they are
because people are atomized people are
lonely and so people the again
liberalism Market forces has snipped
Family Ties Community ties religious
ties all the ties That Bind and so
people are lonely they're atomized in
cities they're a lot more easily
emotional they're easier to to lead to
to Riot to do other things because
they're more emotional they don't have a
family that they need to keep their name
good for reputations for because
everyone's kind of on their own so if
you ruin your own name well it doesn't
matter for your brother or someone else
you're kind of all your own individuals
that's something the USSR and other
nations totalitarian states did
purposefully we kind of got here
accidentally that's what I was trying to
say earlier when I forgot my words they
did that intentionally where they had
the state come in and they snipped those
ties they destroyed ethnic groups that
were very strong on religion very strong
on Family Ties they would Deport them
move them you know do whatever and then
again go after church make it
subservient to the state or just shut it
down in general and then on and on
because they're getting people out of
the peasant areas because that's where
tradition usually survives longest and
they were pushing people into the cities
you saw China do this even through like
the 80s and 90s when they were on the
come up before they pushed Japan out to
become the world's second largest
economy again and again you saw that
again those totalitarian regimes they
were doing that purposefully because
they don't want they want you listening
to the state first and foremost and not
to your family to your pastor whoever
forgive me but we got here accidentally
all right I don't agree it was
accidental okay oh well well yeah okay I
get that give me your theory as to how
it happened well I mean it could be
accidental in the sense that there was
just a bunch of policies that were
completely ill-conceived and moronic
maybe or it could be that you know you
you had the war on drugs and you broke
the black family and you create all
sorts of Discord that happens there
um then you have obviously the
militarism that has persisted throughout
my entire adult life in far longer than
that I think that ultimately those
things alone will kind of unmoor a
society it starts to degrade the culture
the underlying culture the the ties it
behind then you have obviously the uh
the not the Advent but the popularity
that came uh in the atheist movement
over the past 20 years I think was
really interesting and keeping in mind
I'm not a religious person but I think
that it's it's quite evident in
hindsight that there is a major price to
be paid when you have people that give
up on religion and they make the state
their God and that and that is what I
see being very pervasive amongst the
young people I think saying bring up
social media and how that's also
atomizing things is is very true I was
got up this morning pretty early and I
logged on to steam to play some video
games and when I did my dad logged on to
play some video games and I was like my
Dad's here and that we didn't talk
didn't message nothing I just saw his
name and I felt his presence but it
wasn't like I was calling him on the
phone there was no communication
superficial connection I think that's
one of the strange part of our modern
world instead of you're absolutely right
uh going to church seeing your family
living near them being connected in a
really authentic way where you can
communicate with them you know
intimately kind of how they're living
their lives what they're thinking about
what their concerns are you get updates
on social media oh this person got
engaged oh this person's moving houses
and it again we're tuned to have this
dissatisfaction culture where it's like
why am I not getting those things why am
I not in those relationships how can I
solve the things who's at fault for that
why don't I have what I want in life I
think part of it is that we don't have a
unifying National culture and we
struggle as a nation because the
geographic size and the complexity of
our makeup to to have that and I think
it became easier to pull people apart
than to bring them together I I think
that the the unifying culture that we
once had was one of you know
bootstrapping it entrepreneurialism I
will find a way through and now
unfortunately because of public
education in my humble opinion you now
have the youngest generation that
believes that they are oppressed
structurally not just because of race
and sexism and all this other stuff but
also because of capitalism they all
believe that capitalism is evil not all
but a huge percentage too I think that
once you have broken that cultural tie
one of like I'm going to find a way to
make it that like that's what the land
of the free the opportunity all this
stuff that's what we used to migrate
here for that's what my great
grandfather came here for and now you
don't hear that talked about very much
from the people that are born here this
is why I think Elon Musk buying Twitter
was so important because I believe that
what we're seeing is just a a i I would
say it's probably more accidental that
when Twitter was created it was the Free
Speech wing of the Free Speech party but
when they Implement these algorithms to
maximize profits they turned a
generation of people around the world
into psychotic deranged individuals so
short so short-sighted though because I
mean yep culturally and and not just
culturally but economically
civilizationally like you're you're
really playing with fire by by feeding
into these algorithmic but no one feels
an obligation to that no one feels like
if you're at the tech entrepreneur and
you could make a billion dollars in a
decade that's what your priorities that
seems like for everything you don't and
where's Jack Dorsey not I have no idea
what happened what happened to his
friend see this is what really bothers
me is that story in SF is sad because
here's a guy who was leaving San
Francisco saying the crime is getting
out of control we gotta go it's his
buddies that did this it was Jack Dorsey
Mark Zuckerberg Susan would just passed
her name these people were just like we
must maximize profits so I got to be
honest the criticism of capitalism I can
get to a certain degree these big
corporations were basically saying
create a social media algorithm write me
code and I wanted to do one thing
I want it to reduce things that cost us
money and increase things that make us
money and because Big Brand advertisers
are terrified of leftist activists you
were more likely to see if Coca-Cola was
emailed by the far left you're offensive
then they'd be like okay stop that
campaign YouTube Twitter Facebook says
we're losing money what's going on well
the activists are mad but conservatives
wouldn't boycott conservatives don't
protest so these companies have nothing
to worry about even right now with the
Anheuser-Busch boycott you still have a
lot of conservatives being like Oh it's
stupid I don't care okay all right so
Anheuser-Busch is looking at it what
happened Nike doubled down in defense of
Dylan Mulvaney because they do not feel
the economic repercussions from
conservatives I gotta I gotta make the
defense of capitalism argument as an end
cap
um ESG I'm right on this shirt
environmental social governance this is
this is exactly how the government is
dictating diversity Equity inclusion
practices in these businesses in their
marketing schemes like this this is not
an organic thing entirely Tim is
absolutely right the algorithms of
social media world the the youth
movement all that's true but that it
wouldn't it wouldn't be this bad you
wouldn't have so many companies that
were insulting their customer base if it
wasn't a financial imperative on the
back end because of BlackRock State
Street Vanguard are functioning under
ESG protocols which dictate that they
will only invest in these companies no
that's true I know but you got it
backwards ESG emerged from this not the
other way around social media companies
like I said Jack Dorsey said we're the
freeze between the Free Speech Free
Speech party so where did ESG come from
the 2005 United Nations so when these
algorithms get implemented this is the
point I made to I can't remember who we
were talking about when it came to uh
academic I think telling philabonti this
as well ESG
and other ideologies how many how many
let me ask you basically how many
ideologies exist right exactly it's
ridiculous there's so many why is it
that only these are prominent today a
vehicle was built by which they could be
pushed onto the masses globally and it
just so happened that what fit those
holes was the likes of ESG correct
there's a bunch of other ideologies that
could have been hey how about white
nationalism oh oh nope Jack Dorsey
banned that stuff in like 2015 and 16
they were like we're getting a lot of
flack from activists we are getting
attacked by the corporate press shut
this part down yeah and then you could
not monetize that content it could not
exist and it would not be influential so
nobody went near it
what happens is people like Jack Dorsey
at one point says I'm all about free
speech then he has a board and investors
say we're not making money here and he
goes it was it was it was not an instant
thing
that what happened that slowly changed
at Twitter was they would get a bunch of
far left activists who would attack them
and they would say hey look we're
getting attacked a lot for this stuff
people are quitting
the far left is much more likely to
boycott protest or quit than the writers
so the economic pressure is just right
there there have been a bunch of
economic ideologies climate change for
instance has not had as easy of a time
as ESG it's funny right climate change
has been around for a long time with
with Al Gore and it's struggled to get a
foothold why because social media
doesn't care there's no monetary
incentive to ban someone who doesn't
care about climate change yeah but the
ESG stuff overlaps with bigotry
homophobia Etc so when someone says
something naughty or racist everybody
says okay whoa whoa whoa hold on there
guys everybody basically agreed we don't
want to see that stuff it gets taken to
an extreme degree the far left throws a
fire bomb and complains and all the
corporations say I don't want to piss
these lunatics off please don't
associate me with those with that kind
of content Twitter then says don't worry
we'll downrank this is literally what
happened YouTube said we will downrank
all of that content so people don't see
it and flag it for demonetization please
please don't leave there was no inverse
pressure from the right to support and
push for things they did like and to
oppose the far left so what happens man
I remember back when they were doing
these weird videos showing kids sex toys
and this is like 2013 2014 it's like
during gamergate that stuff was all
happening conservatives did not have
that as a as a corporate platform
conservatives have have been behind the
the uh behind on this the entire time
simple example act blue and win red the
Democrats have had an online digital
fundraising platform act blue and it
took the Republicans like three or four
years to figure it out and make their
own that's how far behind they were well
there's two reasons in my estimation one
the conservatives allow the progressives
to raise their children so how do you
happen how are you gonna how are you
going to compete with activism when you
don't have kids that actually share your
values I think you're you're
automatically at a at a dead end in that
regard uh sorry go ahead oh no oh no
sorry
um I was I was just thinking through a
few things as you were talking about it
it is interesting that a lot of people
say start out saying I'm Free Speech or
I'm this or that and then they find
themselves on the opposite end of it I
wonder if there's something
psychologically because I've noticed
with some people I think maybe this is
just something all humans deal with here
like your own internal biases that you
feel like at heart you're a good person
right everyone kind of feels about them
so it's like my motivations are pure I'm
good so I could never be that which I
abhor even when you become that monster
you know so I wonder if there's kind of
that where some of these people go well
I do still believe in free speech but
you're Banning conservatives you're
Banning this or that well they're not
exactly and it's like this weird switch
that it's like kind of like almost a
wall that comes down that almost people
don't realize it's like this weird idea
that I can never be that monster that I
went up to slay I think there's a
hierarchy of what they believe is
Justified right like free speech can be
sacrificed at the expense of this
person's feelings or shielding someone
from this like there are times when
you're allowed to compromise their
values and for other people you know
free speech is at the top number one you
wouldn't sacrifice it for anything
exactly Matt I saw this tweet about the
Great Awakening Mata glacias one of the
founders of vox.com said unpleasant
chart it contradicts my my theories and
my presumptions Matthew Iglesias had
previously said that the rise of
wokeness was due to the fact that gen Z
was paying attention and that as they
were reading the news and getting
exposed to the stories they were then
putting it at the Forefront of their
minds and then he explained something
like I I think it was quoting
alcazio-cortez that gen Z is depressed
because they know reality and that's
actually really not true no the reality
is they're they're in a fake a fake
reality yes
they're being they're being set a
feedback loop of psychotic algorithmic
content I agree it is making them insane
and violent I gotta you have to it can't
be just the algorithm though because
this this concept wouldn't have been
viable to me as a child neither would
have white supremacy or white
nationalism correct but it was banned so
that's not in your you're not wearing a
shirt saying white supremacy is evil no
but that's kind of given if right but
here's the thing what if Twitter was
promoting outright white supremacists
and neo-nazis you would be wearing a
shirt being like what is going on in
this country with the right what that's
why this happened certain ideologies
were outright eliminated from the
conversation right and it was because
advertisers found one to be socially
acceptable and it's a combination of
reasons as I mentioned
before social media most people in this
country are like dude I don't like
racism like we had gotten past that yeah
so any attack on something as racist
would cause Panic among someone who
didn't want to be called a racist this
meant the far left could accuse you of
being a white supremacist for no reason
it went to absurdity Larry Elder is the
black face of white supremacy right
because they use something like that to
convince us to adhere to it so a an
Advertiser that sells uh vitamins all of
a sudden they're getting attacked saying
you sponsored a white supremacist and
they go we I had no idea in their mind
they're thinking the clan but the left
is lying and they're saying conservative
but these Brands don't know anything
about politics and they say I had no
idea we did this you guys you've got to
apologize
the vagrama Swami mentioned that his his
moment when he came into the into this
into the culture war was he's running
this pharmaceutical company black lives
matter riots happen and he gets asked to
to give a statement and so he was like
uh sure I guess and so he makes a
statement like you know this is you know
it's it's horrible to see these kinds of
things happen let's come together as a
country and try to find a way through
this and then he was like the next thing
I know they're saying it wasn't strong
enough it didn't meet the moment and
then six advisors resigned from his
company he's like what is happening
because he didn't get to his knees and
screamed the High Heavens that's what
the left has been doing selectively
manipulating and then you get people who
are scared of them to fall in line but
simply put there are there there are a
hundred different ideologies like Ron
Paul
the Ron Paul libertarian ideology was
massive yeah and then what happened well
the reason it was massive it's genuinely
a good idea the Libertarians had a lot
of great ideas you may disagree with me
so I'll leave you alone hey that really
works for me that's what I liked about
Ron Paul
so in 2007 2008 the internet was flush
with this stuff the Ron Paul Love
Revolution I like to mention mike.com
went woke originally started as more
libertarian you know Ron Paul like but
the algorithms were that were the things
that were getting the most clicks were
playing into social justice narratives
so these these media companies just
outright said
whatever makes his money baby I got I
gotta connect these dots because the
it's so you're absolutely right and the
timing is so perfect because you have
the 0809 Great Recession you have the
bailouts that come with that you have
they End the Fed chants that are
happening with Ron Paul in 2008 and then
all of a sudden out of nowhere Klaus
Schwab identifies this ESG concept this
anthropogenic global warming concept
this wokeness concept this inclusion
concept and it's just perfect timing
they flip all of the animosity that's
going towards the banks and they put it
right back on to but that way you're
being impressed by race yeah I know but
still the time I mean it's still it's
still a redirect from the anger that
came from the Federal Reserves policies
in 0809 I think that's exactly what
happened I I do I I only somewhat uh
agree in that they used wokeness to try
and stop Occupy Wall Street and subvert
these protests but I think when you see
a company like mike.com make the
conscious decision I want to maximize on
far left ideology instead of Ron Paul
libertarian Theology of course it was
all economic I know I I learned this
from an employee I was actually hanging
out it was World Trade Centers one
Freedom Plaza and I'm hanging out with
someone who worked there explaining to
me how they went through that process
and I'm like damn but but don't you
think that given the the
political environment of where big Tech
lives that they could and not to mention
the Twitter leaks and what we now know
about the the intervention from the
federal government in terms of
censorship protocols in terms of service
protocols could it could it not have
been dictated by the government to take
it down this path I don't know so it's
been 10 years we get the start of this
shift through social media algorithms
around 2008 with with Facebook what
happened was you on average people a
person would have 300 friends and Page
likes combined and that meant your news
feed would move fairly quickly
eventually people couldn't see anything
and Facebook was like well if they're
not seeing their core friends they're
not sticking around we need an algorithm
that shows them things they're more
likely to interact with so they made it
this resulted in people being inundated
with videos of police brutality videos
of black men being beaten by cops it
created a massive wave of people who are
anti-establishment anti-police in the
beginning though you got a lot of
Libertarians people are like screw the
police these people are bad yeah that's
when I was there but also you had
distrust in government so you ended up
with Ron Paul as sort of the avatar for
this that was the first iteration but as
the algorithms became more and more
pronounced as more people got onto
social media the things that would make
the most money were stories about first
police brutality
tie in some racism to it the article
gets 10 times as many views interesting
it's actually like um who was who was
Vivek was telling me this this morning
he said when he asked me if I ever
wanted whitewater rafting and I was like
yes and he goes okay how do you get a
Class 5 rapid when two streams come
together of equal force you don't get a
two times stream you get it 10 times an
exponential boost so when someone wrote
an article about police brutality people
would be like oh but if they wrote about
racist police brutality it would be
massively exponentially increased in
terms of its viewership and I'll tell
you why
the algorithm is programmed so that if
there is an article that within the
first 10 minutes it received 100 views
the algorithm would say show this to a
thousand more people
if it gets a hundred views in the next
five minutes among those thousand show
to ten thousand right if the next five
minutes it gets a thousand show it to
ten thousand more that's the exponential
growth train of how these algorithms
algorithms were basically working right
here's what happens
a video an article about police
brutality is shown to 100 people and 10
people do click it it goes viral an
article about racism is shown to 100
people it goes viral but an article
about racism and police brutality hits
20 people in the first minute two times
so what happens then is the algorithm
exponentially increases the the blast
off of this it then says whoa whoa whoa
how many did we get in the first 10
minutes a thousand whoa this must be a
good article show it to a hundred
thousand people right now and if ten
thousand people click on it and then it
would and then this one article would
get set to 10 million people in one hour
so that was an exponential burst this
led to inter the rise of
intersectionality feminism first it was
feminism it was women's rights and then
the question became how is it that we we
talk about police brutality racism and
feminism but now in 2012 2013 we're
talking about intersectional feminism
because an article that contained sexism
feminism and police brutality would get
100 fold as many views so everyone's
talking about wokeness everyone's
talking about ESG but what I keep I
always remind people is this didn't
start there you can actually watch the
progression of the ideology and how it
was formed it wasn't like Klaus Schwab
drafted this letter submitted to these
companies and then all of a sudden from
2008 to 2010 ESG existed and we were
talking about wokeness and critical race
Theory no no no it started with police
brutality everyone was in favor of Ron
Paul then these companies started to
shift and become woke we introduced
racism into the mix then we had
gamergate video games misogyny and games
you get feminism Anita sarkeesian Etc
eventually you get into the era of
critical race Theory right now critical
race theories graduated critical gender
Theory and in general wokeness you can
actually watch the track that social
media has created this amorphous zombie
horde it's it's very interesting but the
timing it just continues to give me
pause because 0405 is literally when the
United Nations writes up their their
first conceptual idea of ESG and by
2010-11 the world economic Forum has
already made it like their focal point
and then you're absolutely right though
it doesn't really take over Corporate
America or the global corporate
environment until 2009 I think that's a
confirmation bias because what you're
not talking about is any other corporate
plan or ideology introduced by global
Elites except for that one it's because
it's the one you know
well it's also the one that's the most
evil but yeah there was also talk about
doing uh black currencies I remember
Alex Jones talked about this 20 years
ago on North American currency this is
before the euro and then the Euro
happened the Amero and there was big
talk about an economic plan but often
what happens is they'll float an idea
and if it doesn't go anywhere just
Fizzles in fact that's how everything we
have a chance to fizzle cbdc right now
Central Bank yeah that thing's crap so
anyway they're gonna back door that the
the Amero conversation is interesting
right we're not talking about the Amero
anymore no it was the idea was that
there would be Canada the US and Mexico
sharing one currency I remember Alex
Jones talked about it a whole lot never
happened never happened why
just there's a lot of ideas they flooded
that never took off yeah a lot of
conversations that happen that everyone
anywhere the Advent of Central Bank
digital currencies and and Bitcoin and
blockchain Technology I think kind of
forces them to regroup and come come up
with a new scheme which will probably be
the same Bitcoin didn't matter until
what 2014. yeah but when we're talking
about the Amero 2000 2002 2003 right so
so why did my point is just this
why didn't that why aren't we sitting
here complaining about the attempt to
implement a North American currency but
you are wearing a shirt about ESG a
bunch of ideas were presented some of
them persisted that's it I don't think
it's that they were like in 20 years
this will be the plan although it might
have only because the Twitter files are
pretty eye-opening and we see that the
FBI has been in there telling them what
to do maybe a decade ago they were also
like we don't I don't know that's my
concern is do we know that these like
Tim's saying that it just became more
viral and more profitable I'm saying
couldn't you if you had control of the
algorithm setting couldn't you make
anything go viral essentially
so the issue in your network right you
would have to believe that these people
came up with a plan for ESG in 2005 and
then
the other people came up with other
ideas just there were dummy ideas they
were they were proxy ideas meant to
confuse and distract us and then once
the social media companies existed they
planted people within those companies
not to implement their plans right away
but to only implement the first page of
their 100 page plan through the idea of
feminism then they'd have to write an
algorithm that would guarantee the
promotion of racism and police brutality
but not at the same time but my point is
this I watched all this that we have the
data showing the rise in this
terminology over years and the hockey
sticks and the spikes I'm going the
opposite direction though I'm saying I'm
saying what if they already have this
this Playbook and then they're looking
at what is fertile ground here we have a
whole bunch of kids that have been
raised in the public school system to be
very anti-racist very Progressive in
nature we're going to formulate our
protocols for power accumulation using
what we will think will already work on
this population does that make sense to
me sure but what what makes more sense
in my opinion is is there's
let's let's say there's a guy named
schwaus club and he believes in hardcore
laissez-faire capitalism he sounds
awesome and right now he's sitting in
his in his uh lair in schwitzaland going
it is a shame that our plan didn't work
no and the other elitist Psychopaths
we're not discussing because they didn't
make it yeah what I think is more likely
is of the ten Psychopaths that were you
know you know Plinko yeah you dropped a
little thing and there's a little Pags
that goes but then you're hoping it goes
in the Middle where the 1 million
dollars is you put 10 psychotic Global
Elite you know Millionaires and
billionaires you drop them and their
pegs bounce around and then one of them
lands right in the middle and that's
Klaus Schwab and then we're going here's
his plan here's how he did it and I'm
like no there were a bunch of other
people trying to do a bunch of things
they just didn't fit the mold you know
what's wild about this this uh thing you
pulled up this diagram here is that look
at Cuba Cuba's the Communist place it's
the one that in 2000 was extremely high
up on the the other one started low and
became talking about racism and sexism
but it was already happening in Cuba and
then it dipped but look I was in five
after the war in Iraq but look at Iran
Iran had spikes and a stable medium rate
of this of these conversations look at
Malaysia there was actually a spike
early in the 2000s it dipped a little
bit spiked again there are some
countries South Africa had a huge spike
in South Africa started off very it
started off high similar to Cuba not as
high as Cuba so Cuba was all the way at
the top and South Africa he was going
through apartheid here's what here's
what here's what I do think your
observation tells us
we are all heading towards communism I
completely agree it seems like a
communist tactic for sure and yeah
social media's adopted it probably
unwittingly through their algorithmic
manipulation I would believe what's more
likely is that as these things started
to emerge Communists noticed and then
exploited it to an extreme degree yeah
but but it's it's the people keep this
Falls in line with what I talk about
with wokeness when people are like
wokeness is these these leftist theories
that emerge and it's like no no no go
and talk to a woke person and I think
the reason I'm I differ from many of
these these you know conservative
independent thinkers about what wokeness
is is because I was at Occupy Wall
Street is because I spent a decade on
the ground with these people
and I've found that they don't believe
anything they like yeah Ukraine war and
I'm like what does that have to do with
the Frankfurt School nothing right it's
a cult that's it that's why I think I
think what you're talking about with
like the kind of internal momentum of
the algorithm and stuff but also it has
there has to be fertile ground there as
well for why these you know racism and
other buzzwords were catching on the
same way that they were and then kind of
like creating almost a death spiral
because then like more and more it was
kind of coalescing as I think in some
ways and also maybe why some of these
other nations sometimes kind of use the
talking points is because it speaks to a
real pain that I think people feel a lot
of people are economically insecure a
lot of people do feel like the state is
rigged against them and again those are
quite real concerns and then as you said
but the state doesn't want a solution to
say like a Ron Paul or an adjacent type
view because then that takes away from
their power so they're gonna boost up
these other you know again whatever you
want to call them the different you know
like woke is and whatever you want to
call because it kind of funnels back to
you well the state is good and the state
will protect you from XYZ these threats
that we've you know identified and we
will fix this problem together and so I
I wonder if that may be one because
again I think because what also gets
boosted is the typical Republican right
and you know I don't know where I am
right now I feel like I'm in a weird
place ideologically
um I'm very conservative in my beliefs
but I find myself I love a lot of
Libertarians Scott Horton you know the
rest are good friends I really love them
I like a lot of their critiques and
stuff and what it kind of opened my eyes
to was it was one thing when I was 16
years old at my high school Republican
class right you know um you know we had
our little high school group and stuff
and it's pick yourself up by the
bootstraps come on kid get out there
work my bat and dad used to you my
grandpa you saw that kind of thing well
then I get out to the real world on my
cloud this sucks everything is rigged
against you that's really tough you try
and get a job when you're this happened
to me when I was 18 19 20 could not get
a job at even McDonald's Panda Express
nothing was taking me and I'm like I'm
not dumb hopefully I'm not you know a
bad kid I don't have any great issues
there's nothing so why am I not being
hired and I'm not getting hired but 16
year olds could get hired at some of the
jobs I was 19 sometimes they tell you
well you know we will actually something
my friend told me because she was also
having similar issues that at that time
California was raising minimum wage and
so they were saying well they're going
to pay you more they're going to want
someone who maybe has spouse kids or has
more work experience than you and I'm
like even in low-level jobs and she's
like well yeah and so I kind of started
to realize like well I can't get my foot
in the door anywhere everyone's
everywhere is telling me well you want
to be like a grocery bag or you need
five years experience like I know
hyperbole there but that was kind of the
idea I'm like well how can I get
experience if no one's given me that
first job and so then I realized well
then if that's how that is how am I
going to get an apartment and then how
come Apartments where I live are like
two plus Grand it's not what my mom and
dad pay for mortgage wait a second then
how am I going to save up money for a
house they're five six seven eight
hundred thousand dollars and then I
realize like oh normal Republican are
talking points are not meeting people
where they're at what's up people are
dealing with real issues and they're not
feeling hurt a lot of young kids grew up
hearing and I felt this too a lot of
Republicans hear this too saying you got
to go to college you got to go to the
best university your life is over or
teachers would pound that into your your
coaches would tell that to you so you
finally do it you go to university now
you're in a lot of debt you can't get a
job for the reasons I mentioned earlier
you're making 30 grand a year you don't
know where you're maybe rooming with
three or four people because you can't
make rent and then you have people
telling you you went to college and you
took out that loan you dummy yeah look
at you and then you feel like you're
just being yelled at by the same people
who told you to go down that life path
so I'm a conservative but I kind of like
the specific strain I am I don't know
because I want to meet people where they
are because that's why so many kids are
going off on these left because at least
they feel heard and like you're right
Tim a lot of them they don't have like a
strong ideological position as to why
they just hurt a lot of what are what do
we do with young people suicide is
extremely high drug overdoses a lot of
kids are doing escapism because they
don't know they just grow up hearing you
know everything's evil you know if you
get married have kids get a job
you're only working for the man and then
kids who actually do want to do that
they find it's very hard to do this so
they kind of feel like wow I don't know
I'm tugged in both directions and then
this is the only side that it seems like
they're listening to my pain at least so
I'll just mold myself to whatever the
problem is is that they're prescribing
more poison to alleviate what is already
exactly damaging them so uh I agree with
you though it doesn't it doesn't reach
them because they have gone through 12
plus years of indoctrination into this
ideology so if you just go well in truth
it's actually the minimum wage it's the
reason that you weren't able to get a
job and now uh that's why you went to
college you took on all the student loan
and it's all actually all a product of
the government but then you have a guy
who's running for president who's like
I'm gonna get rid of that student loan
and you're not the problem here they're
like well that sounds awesome I couldn't
tell you how many people because I did
go to university who were like Bernie
Sanders sounds great free college like
that would be a great idea this is the
worst I'm gonna graduate with debt I
think you're completely right that
people uh
I love a lot of the ideology that comes
with being conservative I think you know
working hard and being self-reliant are
honorable skills but what does that look
like when you're 18 and you have no work
experience or I don't have a lot of work
experience and no one will hire you I
think it's easy to become discouraged
because that's the best thing about
being young you are incredibly hopeful
and optimistic and you just want to go
and do all the things but if you can't
move out of your parents house and gain
independence because you are financially
strapped from the beginning it becomes
uh sort of difficult to look at that
person saying like well just try harder
keep working and be like are you kidding
yeah you do have to work this is a big
part of it is you need to work 12 hours
a day to succeed in this life especially
now you need to be the one that's there
first or at least that you're willing to
spend 12 hours doing what you love five
days a week and you know what what he
was just talking about with the
algorithm it's like that eight hours
it's the Baseline that everyone else is
putting in well you double it and then
it actually creates an exponential
growth curve once again and if you can
do that earlier then that curve has a
chance to Arc even more exponential as
you get older so like I did the same
thing in my 20s and because of that I
was able to retire at 37 years old
like most of my friends were not willing
to make those sacrifices so if you can
if you can actually view it that way
like where if you just make it a little
bit better if you do 10 more or 20 more
when you're younger that exponential
growth curve actually works in your bit
in your uh and then what you do it's
really simple you uh in 2010 buy Bitcoin
well that that helps too buy a few
thousand of them and then just forget
and then times later you're a
billionaire investment is certainly part
of it because it's the same way you work
more you make a little bit more than
everyone else the Investments start to
Compound on themselves I think you have
to make choices that you that don't
sound glamorous in today's day and age
like it sounds more fun to live in the
city and get to do whatever and spend
all your money but like is it more
financially prudent to live somewhere
that's more expensive or less expensive
so you can save money to eventually buy
property I think it's difficult in
Indulgence culture which is what I
completely believe we're in right now to
say look you have to make a decision for
your long term we live in a now culture
like I want satisfaction right now I
don't want to have to say notice
something knowing eventually it will
lead off like you're saying like you had
to put in extra work when you were young
but I don't want you because I want to
go off and do this other thing and the
reason kids won't is because they have
so much hopelessness that it's like I
would rather because I'm going to be
battling this battle forever well then
let me enjoy now you know but I didn't
feel that way when I was a kid yeah so I
think that's a huge that's just a
heartbreaking the amount of people I say
hear her like well I'll never be able to
buy a house I'll never be able to get
married I'll never do whatever it's sort
of like yeah I would I would hate all of
this too and that's all fed policy and
this is why the Libertarians and this is
why I get so activated about Federal
Reserve even though it's so wonky and so
cold and dry and such a boring concept
to most people but this is the reason
that the Ron Paul Revolution exists this
is the reason that people like me became
so activated because once you understand
that manipulating the money supply the
price of money the most important Market
mechanism that exists well then the
whole system's broken so of course the
young person who knows they're never
going to be able to afford a house
becomes hopeless and lives in the
present and spends and borrows
unnecessarily because they don't think
that they have a future and they're
probably right but who is responsible
for that
well then let me ask you because you
would know obviously a lot more than me
and I am genuinely curious because
obviously there's a term that is getting
a lot of Buzz right now uh anarcho
tyranny right about like Anarchy in the
streets uh tyranny at the top in the
sheets
you know like you could be you could be
a murderer basically in like the streets
of a major city and you can get out you
know with pretty much you know slap on
the wrist but then you don't do
everything correct on your taxes the IRS
is me knocking on your door saying those
threading letters and stuff so anarcho
tyranny is there something similar
because you're right we are living in
like almost like a gluttony age and
overindulgence age but yet we also don't
have what we need so is there there's
like a weird thing like young people
today like we have all the new phones we
have fast fashion we have a lot of like
cheap stuff and I know a lot of the from
some of the Libertarians I was again
dipping my toes and I don't know as much
right now but they were saying like with
inflation over time that a lot of goods
are made more cheaply now for sure
because of that and so I wonder if
there's like a similar term to describe
like as Anarchy tyranny but for like our
our Goods where you have a lot of young
people who were satiated and
overindulged in these kind of like
trivial matters you know by the video
games by the fast fashion we can go to
the mall we have that kind of money but
we don't have the money for what
actually matters in life like the home
the car the marriage the whatever so
it's almost like because again when I
was coming up as an army conservative
this what would I always say to young
people why are you so depressed were you
living the most wealthiest prosperous
time ever and and that is true but then
also you're looking at well people are
spiritually impoverished people don't
have the same faith in God and family
because back in the day you're ill your
family's there to take care of you now
it gets kind of outsourced in a sense
you get sent to the old people's home
and they're they're fueled by Envy right
yes they they think they should have
these things and they don't have them so
you're becoming immensely frustrated
with society and again we have taught
people that well actually all your
problems are someone else's fault right
but keep in mind too that because you
now have uh Social Security and Medicare
Medicaid like your your
your assumption is that you don't need
your children to take care of you in old
age so so what does that mean you don't
necessarily care about taking care of
your kids it doesn't give as much of an
incentive to do so if you're most if
you're a good person you're going to do
it anyways but I'm just saying like all
of this is incentive manipulation that
comes as a byproduct of State
intervention into our culture our
economy most specifically and then it
trickles down into the economy and it
degrades the foundation this is why I'm
such a big proponent of Bitcoin because
I believe that it has the capacity to
remedy many of these cultural ills so
we'll see how it plays out but I I think
that ultimately the reason I don't agree
with Tim that this will be a uh the new
religion of the next Millennia or
whatever is because it is a it is
self-devouring it we will end up in ruin
if that is the case and I just I refuse
to believe and then a real religion will
appear because some profit that's my
belief
or um
for the new religion is actually
abrahamic then it'll be some Resurgence
of CR of Christianity actually yeah I
think so so
in responsibility yeah I think there are
there's some revivalism yeah especially
in like other I think it's Kyrgyzstan
right now there's some crazy uh wave of
young people like there are countries
where the biggest growth of children's
is among young people which of course it
would have to be if you're going to
develop a religious Country Now what if
these are the end times Revelation and
what is that impossible what is actually
going to happen is the new religion will
actually be set
after the second coming
so all of these things that are
happening like the mark of the beast you
cannot buy or sell unless you bear the
mark and things like that what if all
these things really are coming true
and then there is the second coming and
then the new religion for the age of
Aquarius actually is the ex the the the
newest you know expansion upon
Christianity to the next the only
downside of that I love it but I don't
like waiting for someone to come save us
because we have to save ourselves this
is a reoccurring theme absolutely the
second coming is within all of us like
each of us if each of us can step up and
become the Christ in our own life and
treat other people with that I think
that's like the Resurgence or the new
society that can overcome corporate
greed other than that corporate greets
to power I don't see anything other than
other than oh state power is way more
powerful than corporate green
like just the barrel of a gun yes
Weaponry yeah yeah you rated a few
weaponries to change the minds of the
people that like weapons you or the
hearts of them even state government can
raid a fortune 500s office and arrest
the top Executives except and then
destroy the company but McDonald's can't
go arrest the president but who runs the
show is it the state of the United
States or is it Halliburton and Lockheed
but not Albert Lockheed Martin I mean
it's a revolving door so like who knows
but regardless the the Monopoly on
violence exists within the state not
within the corporation so I think that
they take the cake in terms of power uh
wielding
are do you care do you get into like
Revelation do you have you studied that
stuff much well am I going to be saved
or not so I'm a Catholic
um so for me I know I think price even
says in the New Testament that even he
doesn't know the hour nor the day so
that's not something I if Christ
himself's not going to buildings he's
the God man I'm not gonna
um predict or anything um what I do know
is obviously all of us are gonna die um
whether or not the second coming comes
first before that doesn't matter we're
all gonna die and so to get ourselves
right with God one thing I know in my
personal life is I see God moving
through my life very obviously bringing
me first of all here to this fun podcast
with all of you lovely people
um into my job and stuff so I'm a very I
have my scalp scapular actually on right
now so I I think I think I figured it
out or finished I don't want to
interrupt oh no where is that what is
that I think I figured it out
so here's what I think happened Klaus
Schwab you know when he was a teenager
he acts he he he he was depressed and
angry and he tried to take his own life
but only briefly as he was resuscitated
but in that tiny moment he was sent to
hell because it's a mortal sin to commit
suicide and for him it felt like an
eternity but he was resuscitated and now
he knows that he's committed this mortal
sin and no matter what he does when he
dies he's going to hell so he is trying
to you know seek immortality and then
create this new dominant religion and
take over maybe that makes it never hell
on Earth he'll Live Forever This is
actually the theme of like two different
things like Constantine the movie where
he's like he knows he's going to hell
because when he was a kid he tried to
kill himself and then I think this was
um Shadow lands in World of Warcraft uh
Sylvanas was like no matter what I do
I'm going to like this whatever region
so she shatters the veil between the
afterlife because she was like if I'm
going everyone's going with me I will
say one interesting thing that I notice
in one of my producers he's actually
filling in for me today Chris Boyle uh
one of our big conversations is it's
interesting that in your rights of the
The Atheist age came in I think a lot of
that is actually motivated by Big Data
the idea that see man you're nothing we
can we can predict everything about you
so there's actually nothing special and
unique about you it's kind of like the
idea you were just where Earth is
nothing special it's just a floating
Rock and it's one of many planets yada
yada however it doesn't resonate with
people like maybe at first when you're
kind of rebellious and a kid whatever
but I think people kind of grab that
because the need for belonging for
higher purpose it's everything because
if you look from the beginning of time
and even on like you know what you can't
see in the invisible world of pathogens
and stuff everything's eating each other
everything's killing each other
sometimes you feel like you know it's a
struggle to stay alive every day and yet
we still find meaning and purpose even
though we know that so I I think one
thing that we've noticed a lot right now
with politics specifically is that even
the officials like religion is kind of
you know obviously talk about the Pew
numbers going down uh people affiliating
as nuns as like none as in religious
affiliation but you see a Resurgence
almost in like witchcraft occult you see
that a lot on Tick Tock for young people
the crystal shops everywhere tarot card
shops everywhere palm reading I know in
Ukraine they were doing the Viking like
um you know Pagan ritual for some of the
deceased Fighters they were one of their
state official accounts was doing hexes
so it is kind of strange it's similar to
how like Dawkins and stuff they would
say we don't believe in God or higher
power and yet they talk about Evolution
and natural selection in a way like it
was an omnipotent yeah it's like it's an
omnipotent Force I'm like but this is
just accidents it's not like a guided
Force but they were talking about like a
guy force people talk about the universe
or Karma like it's almost a God but I
don't believe in a sky Daddy but the
universe is directing me I'm like wait a
second so C.S Lewis would say that in
the same way we hunger because we need
food to live we thirst because we any
drink to live we hunger for the Divine
for worship for adoration it's a
universal that through anthropology that
all human cultures that we found had
some have some Supernatural belief
attached to them it's something that
mankind is it's like innate in us we're
looking for that proper outlet for it
um but I think that's why we can never
get away from the Paradigm of man has to
worship something so politics otherwise
Murray rothberg wrote an anatomy of the
state that it in the absence of his
books right now good you're on your way
you're going to be one of us in no time
uh in the absence of the state that
there would either be statism or
scientism and and that the state would
probably use scientism and then you look
at Anthony fauci I was rereading anatomy
of the state during the lockdowns and I
was like I know exactly what you are
Tommy I don't consider myself uh
Christian I say this all the time I
believe in God I don't really follow any
like scripture of any religious
institution but I gotta say over the
past few years The more I've seen the
more it certainly felt like Angels and
Demons the more it feels like a
nefarious malevolent presence seeking to
subvert something more Divine in this
world well then allow me if you'll
you'll allow me to um
to positive at one Theory so obviously
like I think that your algorithm I
Theory I think that that is very very
true to kind of how we got here and
everything's kind of exploded because a
lot of people say it seems like it just
kind of came out of left field a lot of
this stuff and I know the I ideologies
go back many decades but I think one
thing is at least for me as a Catholic
so again this is just my theory of
people who just can take or leave I'm
not trying to push anything on any it's
just something to kind of mull over one
idea that I think is strange is how I
can be doing my show on a random Tuesday
night we're talking about I don't know a
drag queen who's naked dancing in front
of kids and you see the moms brought the
kids there for this for the express
purpose of seeing a naked dance they're
not shocked they're like oh I didn't
know I thought this was family friendly
like they're there for that reason
actually you've seen the wall and the
Washington Post there's a woman who
wrote saying yes I bring my toddler to
uh to Gay Pride parades for the Kink and
I want them exposed to that so I think
wow this is very strange how and why for
me at least as a Catholic believing in
the Trinity God the Father God the son
God the Holy Spirit they're a family at
heart reflected in the holy family which
is a representative of them on Earth and
including the God man himself so he's in
both so Saint Joseph then the Blessed
Virgin Mary and Jesus so the mother
father become one through marriage and
then through their love they create a
child they're open to that new life so
sexual love and you see a lot of saints
actually in the Catholic church talk
about ecstasy Climax and stuff and
sexual relations that it's a shadow of
things to come a full Union with God
because for us as Catholics the idea of
being in the church is your spouse of
Christ and so the idea for Heaven is
that you are fully one with God in a
spousal Union that's why throughout the
Bible uh wedding feasts are so prominent
the wedding Feast of Cana the marriage
Feast of the Lamb Heaven being described
as a wedding Feast as a feast itself so
a lot of is these kinds of themes so if
God is the foundation of all reality and
all that exists and love is the center
of that and sexual relations on Earth
which is why the church why we have
morality so strongly it's not because we
have arbitrary rules it's because it's
guiding your soul to grow and to be
better and not to be deformed or
malformed well then if all of this is
true no wonder that when you pull away
God and try and remake Society in your
own image because that's what leftism is
right that reality is not itself it can
be manipulated can be changed we can
remake reality so if that's true if
that's what we're trying to undo then no
wonder this the seam that we see
splitting is sex specifically whether
it's the drag queen story hours whether
it's just any of these other debates
that we're having I think women that
women vote Democrat men vote
conservative
yeah
all right shall we go to super chats
let's do it if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends if you do like
it and become a member by going to
timcast.com and clicking join us to get
access to the uncensored members only
show archive we do those live Monday
through Thursday at about 10 10 p.m and
you can join the Discord and chat with
other like-minded individuals build
community and other cool stuff we're
going to be doing we didn't do it today
but we've we've set up a system by which
we can now select companies that our
members actually run or or programs they
have
so that's our sponsor spot for Fridays
so hopefully we'll get that going next
week meaning if you're a member you're
basically sponsoring the show already
we'll shout out one of your com we'll
shout out a company from each of you
once per week I'm really excited for it
um let's uh let's read some more uh
let's read some super chats
all right shaky owns says I got an email
about a Tim cast gift and was told it
would be shipped by the end of the week
but I haven't heard anything not
complaining just curious
um I think I heard something about that
dude do we know what that's about no
someone well someone was telling me
something they were going to be sending
members some stuff so maybe I'm wrong
I've seen some updates in the Discord I
don't know if that has anything to do
with it but I know there is like every
day uh
Brett and Andrew are working on that
Discord and improving it yeah
yeah maybe maybe you got randomly
selected for some promo or something so
all right
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim my dude
are the culture war is only getting
better or is that just me not sure about
Vivek but now I'm digging him you turn
us on to so many yeah I I guess
um the latest episode of the culture War
podcast it's episode number seven
youtube.com timcast or check it out on
Apple on Spotify I had a two-hour
conversation with Vivek ramaswamy and uh
man that dude is very very smart I'm
really excited to see him on the debate
stage he's running for president
obviously as a republican I think he's
going to give I I think he already just
pushes DeSantis way way down he makes a
sentence look like when people are like
I think it's going to be Trump or
DeSantis I'm like I'm not so sure
depending on how much attention Vivek
can actually get his knowledge of all of
this stuff be it ESG the culture wars
corporations Pharmaceuticals his
tenacity his calls to action I think
actually are substantially better than
Rhonda Sanders but we'll see can I ask
one question yeah I've read his book and
uh vivek's awesome I think I could
like cake yeah I could not appreciate
him more for shedding light on ESG when
he did he was doing it very early along
with James Lindsay and others
um only thing that I really have a
problem with
tripling down on the war on drugs and
and oh is that is that one of his
positions he wants to he basically said
he's going to threaten The Mexican
government that if they don't if they
don't shut the border down and keep the
drugs from flowing across fentanyl
specifically that then he will go to war
against the cartels and it's like well
first off as an anti-war guy but also
someone who doesn't believe that
prohibition of drugs works I can't
believe that this is an appealing stance
to take I disagree to a certain extent
talking about securing the border and
stopping human trafficking and drug
smuggling is like I think we need a
border well I'm fine with that but you
honestly think you honestly think
they're going to stop drugs Tim come on
I I think I think Vivek is an outsider
candidate who who is actually serious
about securing the border and and I
think you could I think he could secure
the Border I don't think he's going to
stop the flow of drugs
saying War on Drugs is different like
War on Drugs typically refers to like
non-violent offenders being put in
federal prison if we're talking about
cartels which are murdering people and
like stringing them up and stuff like
that well I think that's a fairly
popular position that we don't want that
to happen I will but you know with him
on this thank you for bringing that up
yeah all right Tracer says for my
channel membership birthday I wish for a
Tim Emoji with red laser eyes and a
ghost girl Emoji but let Mary decide
what it should be well all right um I
don't know someone in discord's gonna
make it I think yeah someone in Discord
could absolutely yeah if someone in
Discord makes that we could use you know
do you see the one of you but it looks
it's like a religious figure with a
chicken it's like they didn't want to
post it because it was like is this too
racy to post publicly because it's like
he was like a saint yeah and I was asked
like oh you want to run that I was like
whoever made that Stellar job it was
you know those candles where it's like a
saint and he's like it was me with a
chicken in his skateboard or something
and I was like but I wouldn't want to
actually sell that because of the
religious iconography I wouldn't want to
I wouldn't I wouldn't assert that you
know but it was it AI I wonder let me
know might have been all right what do
we got here John Kirsten says forget
vosh and Kirk or destiny and Smith the
pairing we actually need is door and
Bannon I'll ask him
but the pairing we actually need is
poker with the boys Jimmy Dore playing
poker with Steve Bannon hell yeah and
ocasio-cortez oh my God so I actually
think
um there's a possibility for some
Democrats to actually come and play if
the goal of the show is simply it's a
game of poker we're not here to debate
politics but we will have playful
ribbing as long as it's not specific so
making a joke being like you know if AOC
was playing with Matt Gates and then
Matt you know raised a bet she was like
you think I'm gonna believe anything
this guy says like jokes like that I
think we actually would see some
Democrats be willing to come and play if
it was like we're not here to go to war
we're here to like this is more like you
know wave the White Flag we have fun we
be human it's about building Rapport as
opposed to actually debating ideas but I
still got to be honest I really doubt
most of them would just say no screws
yeah most wouldn't do it because they
would know Their audience is going to be
like how dare you do that some of them
would do it it'll be after this show
it'll be a Friday night show right yep
Friday Night 10 30. right after we rap
uh 10 o'clock probably okay but then I
wouldn't be there with the guests for
like half an hour so the show would
start probably with Clint yeah and then
you would be like what up we're gonna
get the game going and then we would the
idea would be to get one guest per week
for that show and then our Friday night
guest if they could as well so we would
have two people so like you know if we
had the fake ramaswamy we'd be like the
next part of the show is you playing
poker and who do we have who's our other
guest it's like oh it's Dave Smith so
you know two presidential contenders
potentially I don't know Dave wasn't
enough so excited yeah it'd be fun and
it's just it's most it's just table talk
it's not meant to be a serious game so
if you don't understand poker it
shouldn't matter right it's more so
about people being silly goofing off and
having fun
so yeah what do we got here Bryn Terra
Nova says I'm a ride share driver in
Austin with over 14 000 rides given
never again it's not worth the risk yeah
well I wouldn't say quit driving you
know for this I would say don't drive
anywhere near BLM you know when they're
riding that's probably better advice but
I guess the fair point is you don't
think I didn't know that guy didn't know
and it was just wearing his shorts and a
t-shirt and they're like you go to
prison now
Martin Edgar says today was my last day
of work seven years U.S army plus 28
years Postal Service 35 years of federal
service and into retirement on to bigger
and better things to piss off the
leftists so where should I start Tim oh
man the world is your oyster I don't
know contact Scott Pressler and ask him
how you can help register voters and
ballot Chase and ballot Harvest where
illegal yep that's an important thing
nice work too on the career man or woman
whoever you are
nice work
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Ian
after the opening I was like f why is
everything so bad in the dumps but leave
it to Ian to remind us of the good out
there cheers are good sir oh my gosh if
you dude first Rage what's up dude check
out that culture War show from earlier
with him and Vivek that just I watched
like an hour of it before the show and I
mean I just walked in like I turned it
off at 7 15 and walked right up here it
is just it's a it's really good to see
someone that not only is he a
billionaire nearly he's like worth 700
million or something he's he's has
Solutions and he wants to run not on set
he's an idiot that's stupid he's like no
I'm gonna fix this by putting that there
we can do this to make this better I
have faith in this really stunning in a
very very enlightening also did you know
the guy gave six figures to the East
Palestine this dump he really didn't
even publicize it he didn't want to say
it too and he he founded a church there
that was helping people and he gave him
six figures fantastic so you know I I
look I'm I'm I don't I don't pull
punches maybe I'm not the best
adversarially but if I if I say
something I will ask and I've said this
before Trump went down to East Palestine
he brought supplies he bought food he
was with the people and I was like
Marion Williamson didn't do it Rhonda
Sanders didn't do it that they promised
Swami didn't do it and I was like fine
Rhonda Santos hasn't announced but Vivek
and Marion could have gone so I asked
him out right I was like look Marion
Williamson's she's running to she didn't
visit these people and then I was like
also you're running and I had to ask why
you didn't and he said
the first thing is he had just announced
like you know a couple weeks before but
he was like these people actually voted
for Trump trump showed up for them they
were there for him he was there for them
he was like for me if I showed up it
felt like bring a camera I'm like that's
a stunt but he was and it seemed like he
really didn't want to have to say it but
he's like no I wrote a six-figure check
to donate to people who needed it down
there I didn't want to make a big deal
or say anything to anybody I thought
they needed it and then I was like but
you have to say it because if you don't
say it people assume you did nothing and
you don't care right and then if you do
say it people are like oh he's doing a
stunt yeah but he seemed like he I I
think he genuinely was frustrated that
he had to publicly admit to helping
these people because he did not want to
be expected he didn't want to make it
expected let me just say real quick can
you imagine how much better of a world
we would be living in if you could have
Jimmy Dore of the People's Party Dave
Smith the libertarian party RFK Jr as a
Democrat and then Vivek Vivek ramaswamy
as the GOP I'd say much better field
folks that's say much much better let's
have that debate yes let's do it all
right damage controlling says Tim I'm
upset you had the Vivek on your show and
you didn't ask him about the Sunder or
Keening how can you hope to destroy the
heart of Lor Khan and defeat Molag Joe
now is this how you honor the sixth
house
does anyone understand that reference
I'm looking at you it sounds like some
buzzwords up in that was it I don't know
jargon um it feels like a spell cast on
Ian
Lor Khan I think he's making it up
I'm writing a fantasy novel by the way
it's just coming out so easily
all right let's grab some more Super
chats Eric Miller says Tim regarding
poker with the boys why don't you do a
rake cover your cost and the rest goes
to a charity or cause that the Discord
votes on every week that way politicians
can play and their winnings would go to
the rake so I'm the rake that probably
wouldn't work right so here's the thing
we got to pay for the space we got to
pay for the dealers we gotta uh we've
got to pay for the electricity we've got
to pay for General materials we got to
pay for security we have to have a
manager on staff checking people in and
out we've got to pay for I think we're
gonna need three people to run the show
itself because you're going to need
someone to handle General cameras and
stuff like that then you're gonna need
someone to actually when the RFID
readers read the cards tracking bets
going in things like that for people to
be able to follow along
production oh yeah paying for guests to
fly it if we're like hey we want you on
the show that's like that's that's gonna
be like two grand hotel for two or three
days then we got to get the car to bring
them out to where the shop is plus you
want to have some money for the people
to be playing against each other to try
and win well they got to buy in oh it's
going to be that way we're we're looking
we're looking at a standard gaming
license for a buy-in I'm thinking like a
one-two game you know they buying for
300 bucks dude I'm going all in every
time against AOC and then depending on
who it is we like but to a certain
extent we may cover the buy-ins for
certain people if someone's like dude
I'm not really a poker player I don't
want to like we'll we'll cover your buy
and have fun okay but for like we want
it to be a legitimate game where there's
actual table stays that'd be amazing man
there are other options for how we could
run it I think having it be a legitimate
just fun game where poker is ancillary
it's a table talk that makes it work but
we've been trying to figure out how to
do it and we were like maybe the show
will make money in super chats and clips
to the point where we actually can do
that what your idea was right
um but then we want to make sure we can
undercut the competition
we've got three casinos on the East
Coast you've got horseshoe Maryland Live
and MGM then you have if you only go
about an hour north you've got Hollywood
York and Harrisburg I think and then if
you go an hour West you've got Hollywood
Charlestown so there's like five casinos
within a couple hours of each other
anyone could choose to go to I think
there's only four poker rooms how do we
convince people to come to our very
small limited seating club and then
participate in shows like this right we
got to be a really really awesome Place
sure figuring out how to do that is
going to be tough and getting dealers to
come we got to make sure we pay the
dealers more money and guarantees but I
think we can do it we're trying to
figure it out and I'm I'm hoping the
show itself will generate Revenue so
that if we tell people come play here
and there's no rake we don't need to
take a rake because we make money off
the show that people are gonna be like
then why would I go to any of these
other casinos I'll go to the club where
I don't got to beat the beat the house
to try and play this game I'm telling
you if there's no rake you will get a
lot of players right so for people to
understand a rake is when if two people
bet the dealer will take a percentage of
it and put it in the House's stack that
they just take they take it it's usually
three or four bucks for a hand well at
MGM it's five I think Maryland Live and
Hollywood six that means every time a
pot every hand six bucks is taken away
you sit there long enough time you
notice everyone's stack is getting
smaller and smaller and smaller yeah so
over this just in uh Lor Khan is from
Elder Scrolls 3 Morrowind I don't know
you guys played phenomenal game what is
it what is vivekan Morrowind oh Vivek is
a God in Morrowind
I think the tribunal or something Ian
knew the whole time along with uh or the
other gods there are a few of them
yeah so all right the way back says Tim
the fact that it's confirmed that there
were at least 40 feds in the crowd on
January 6 means the conspiracy theorists
were right jars overflowing at this
point was it that there were 40 feds on
the ground or was it there were 40 feds
working with um proud boys was it on the
ground
I haven't seen clear numbers on it so
I'm hesitant to say I saw the story
about 40
informants or something or feds I just
don't know where they were I don't know
I also want to Google it I think there
were feds on the ground for sure I know
there was like six actual pde yeah and
we know they've been testifying in court
with what the case Gone With The Proud
boys I mean sideways says Subway says
amazing interview today Tim really
opened my eyes to A New Perspective I
thought of a nice saying in hearing him
speak wokeness his weakness from uh yeah
that's a good one well look if you I I
thought Vivek was brilliant he's a he's
a he's a really smart guy I want to see
him pull really well in the GOP I want
to see him standing on that stage having
a conversation with Trump because he's
going to bring these ideas up that Trump
will have to address and that's a good
thing because Vivek knows all about it
my favorite part was when he said he was
like if I win I'll have Donald Trump be
an advisor and I'm like that's all bald
and like he'll be my advice but um no
you won't no thanks if you if you guys
like the show share it we were on
episode seven of the culture War it's a
conversational podcast not news oriented
and so you know very chill could use
your support 40 Undercover informants
are on the ground uh wow holy crap
jeez
Clinton Rari says Tim I live in Austin
the D.A withheld evidence to the grand
jury to get an indictment the lead
detective accused the D.A of witness
tampering the whole case was stacked
against Daniel Perry APD said stated it
was an open and closed case of
self-defense then if that's the case
then everybody needs to be hitting up
Greg Abbott being like pardon this man
immediately get him home to his family
no questions
well I'll be in Austin tomorrow we'll
see what happens don't drive it up to
maybe we can have him on the show that'd
be cool Greg Abbott you out there buddy
you're there well who do I got to call
yeah is there somebody I can call you
know because because I'll tell you this
was why I was explaining to Vivek at the
end of the show I'm like we we have what
I think we're the consistently the
biggest live show every night yeah but
our audience size is not relatively big
compared to like Crowder who gets like 2
million people or Tucker Crossing gets 3
million but most people who watch the
largest demographic are moderate former
liberals moderates slightly conservative
individuals that's why we get so many
conservatives who are like you gotta go
on timcast because they know half the
time or I should say a quarter a third
of the audience are people they need to
reach that they don't reach in the
conservative shows and the Liberals
don't get it and so they're seeding that
ground calling me far right or whatever
when the fact that the Ian's on the show
it's like what vosh said he liked you
and he told us I love that guy but like
their whole thing is like no don't go on
Tim okay I know it could be such a fun
that's the illusion of like conflict is
is really it's just like you shatter it
immediately get to the human
and can I just say real fast talk about
like withholding evidence and I feel
like that's becoming more and more
common you hear that a lot especially in
high profile cases such as this one
whether or not happen specifically in
Austin or not is beside the point we
just hear it often I've had officers on
my show who've had to deal with it
um and so we can even talk about you
know to the highest levels with you know
with Alvin Bragg and the Trump
indictment the idea of everyone says all
the legal experts say this is a very
weak case especially trying to for a guy
who's well known for you know reducing
charges and I was trying to make a
misdemeanor into felonies it seems like
he may try to be Bank banking on a judge
who's more in his favor and a jury who's
more in his favor because it's Manhattan
you see this time and time again and
it's kind of the Confluence of factors
of for so many years of since the left
definitely does kind of run the
institutions of making anyone that they
don't like anyone to their right
basically as you know anathema don't go
on their shows don't talk to them don't
associate with them well then it comes
down to even your rights in the legal
courtroom it's like if you want to you
know put up a red flag even if you think
Perry is a murderer whatever it even if
you just want to say well what about his
rights though in this case it's like oh
so you're siding with an evil man right
and then now that's in the conversation
switches to that and now you're not even
talking about legal stuff anymore I just
think that's a scary pattern we're
seeing it really come to fruition
there's two two quick notes I I'm really
grateful in in a sad way that Trump and
also the j6ers have gotten such a raw
deal in the legal system because the
right has been the defender of the legal
system and the policing forever and ever
and I think it's forcing them to
reconsider the the blank check that they
had written them for so long and it's
not to say that you shouldn't support
any cops it's just that like maybe
realize that once the state has a
monopoly on violence and it becomes very
overtly political in nature it may not
be your friend and I think it quite
clearly is not their friend it's the
same thing with social media algorithms
in my opinion that stuff should be freed
no humans can control that and if it
goes into the wrong hands it's disaster
anarchism baby let's go all right funny
farm in Texas y'all says Tim we're
planning to come to Austin to see y'all
Saturday we live two hours away will
your Meetup be in the evening keep up
the excellent job we are fellow chicken
Farmers chickens are great by the way so
we uh we we've been ordering Sushi and
playing poker on Fridays these past few
weeks and then we always take the extra
sushi and the chickens go nuts you guys
have to see it because it is the
greatest thing Giggles like a school
child oh dude he's so happy watching
these chickens yeah
imagine watching chickens play football
and like Roberto Jr the rooster just
watches he chills he doesn't fight for
the fish he lets the girls eat it you
throw it in one runs full speed grabs it
and then they're all running around in
circles they're jumping over stuff
they're trying to Peck it out of each
other's mouths it is a sporting event
that was a favorite part of my attention
whenever you talk about I'm gonna go
live down by the van and by the river or
whatever I always wonder like but where
are the chickens gonna go yeah they're
all chickens there's no way you go
anywhere without your chickens you're
like most devoted chicken owner you have
like a little chicken thing so um as for
the Meetup Saturday so what we're doing
is next Friday is the live event at the
Vulcan theater we're going to be doing
our show in Austin uh the whole week we
have a really amazing lineup of guests
and then tomorrow I'm not having a meet
up I'm just going to be mentioning to
the elite members in the Discord where I
am and that's it because uh I don't like
if I what happened with John rich is
that he was like we should play at my
Honky Tonk downtown Nashville I said
let's do it and then some crazy person
came in and got the whole thing shut
down and the police got called and they
were like we think there's a credible
threat against your life you can't come
and then I said they can't stop me I'll
come anyway and then they were like
there are children outside this building
during the day we like we we strongly
recommend against and I was like okay
you got me like I can't if a crazy
person's threatening to kill me and then
I'm like I don't care that's fine but
it's the downtown area with children and
families so it's like okay well
I can't do it so tomorrow what's just
going to happen is I'll be in Austin and
then I'll just mention at some point in
the evening to the elite members on
Discord hey guys we're hanging out here
if y'all happen to be nearby come swing
by and say what's up but I also for like
the the restaurant we may be at I don't
want to be like it's a meet up and then
have like 50 people show up in the
restaurants like dude what is going on
here like you can't do an event like
this so but I'll be mentioning just the
elite members that if they're around in
Austin so if that's you then I'll just
post it in the Discord where we're
hanging out so people can come say
what's up
all right where we are where where we
are where are we Alabama Elise says it's
in my family and I watch your show
nightly my eight-year-old Gabby was in a
worldwide premiere of a music video on
YouTube last night it would mean the
world to her if you would shout her out
promoting it artist NF song happy oh NF
is cool oh is it yeah he's a he's a
rapper I don't know if I've listened to
this one yet but NF is a rapper he
doesn't curse at all he started like uh
I don't want to say it's like biblical
rap but they're as early stuff did have
a lot of religious uh yeah I think he's
kind of in it so he's cool was it Lisa
Lisa was in this video Gabby Gabby
I don't know I was like what's your name
Lisa Gabby nice work
what's the name of the video uh Happy by
an NF that's exciting I've been in music
videos too that's cool you were just in
one I yes I was I was I was in a
disturbed music video One time we've got
a uh another another couple songs so
there's a song that I wrote that I
played on my Instagram a while ago and I
told Phil I was like
in terms of like strength and gruffness
in the voice it needs to be here here's
where I can go here's where Phil Labonte
can go and I was like I think you might
have to see if you can you know do this
one me on pain I've been practicing no
Phil singing it oh oh you're oh yeah it
feels the right guy Phil is the guy
who's got the Deep strong voice I can
pull like dark harmonies I think that'll
make it hurt I was like let's go it's
the kind of song that needs to be sung
by someone like Phil Labonte and not by
someone like me it's just like it's a
it's a heavy It's A Hard Rock heavier
you know all right what do we got here
normies get out says starlink is down
globally at the moment and has been for
about 30 minutes that was about an hour
ago I saw that story going around world
war three has begun bummer uh how do
it's it's like how does it go down I
don't know was it thousands upon
thousands of satellites yeah that sounds
systemic
yeah about how Russians aren't actually
losing is that what it was sounds like
it so is that what it was like documents
got leak joint Russia was actually
winning the casualties aren't as uh
enormous like they were like one tenth
of the reported which yeah by the way
Douglas McGregor and others have been
reporting
pretty much along those lines for quite
some time yeah well yeah it's crazy to
me that people still believe anything
coming out of the ghost of Kiev I know
man it's all it's obvious but it didn't
just start after Russia invaded the BS
about Ukraine has been persistent for
decades okay I I can I go on a rant
briefly all right so first up the World
Bank and the IMF absolutely destroyed
Russia in the 1990s and I didn't know
anything about this until I read Scott's
book but after the fall of the USSR the
the West broadly but obviously America
being the the leader of the West had
such an incredible opportunity to look
at their fallen flow and say we are
going to welcome you into the capitalist
West because most people don't know this
but the Russian people after the fall of
Communism were extraordinarily open to
the idea of capitalism because they were
like well that sucked let's give this a
go and instead of walking welcoming them
with open arms they were just caked in
the teeth repeatedly by the west and
George Bush's Administration Bill
Clinton's Administration George Bush's
Juniors Administration year after year
you had both Yeltsin as well as Putin
that requested if they could be added to
the U.N or excuse me to Nato
they were laughed off never even given a
consideration and the only requirement
that Putin put on it was that he wanted
to not have to wait in the normal line
which obviously as a nation with over
six thousand nuclear weapons you might
want to go like all right yeah we won't
make you wait 2 000 no 6 out as far as I
know it's six thousand but the reason he
didn't want to wait is because the
hardliners in Russia that were super
anti-west probably would have toppled
him in that interim so he's just like
look slap Us in the NATO he didn't have
the time to wait yeah he's like I can't
wait if you want me in there put me in
there let's let's just accept the fact
that we are European and what do they do
instead they alienate and they drive
them into back-to-back depressions over
a three-year period that greatly
diminishes the the life expectancy of
the Russian people I'm talking late 90s
I was a kid at the time I had no idea
any of this was transpiring and then as
a byproduct of this you now have driven
Russia not only into war that could have
been avoided if our lunatic State
Department hadn't been involved but also
into the arms of the CCP the Communists
who also have nuclear weapons and oh
might I add over a billion people and we
risk World War III now when we none of
this had to happen none of it so you're
correct they have 5977. it was at their
Peak the Soviet Union had forty five
thousand yes and and that was the other
thing that they were doing they were
cutting back on their nuclear Arsenal
they ended the Warsaw Pact they were
doing all of these like signs of good
faith and instead of treating them with
any sort of respect as a nuclear power
they were just left off and abused and
like this is not to justify or write off
Putin's responsibility in the death of
countless ukrainians and it's absolutely
tragic but to right off the West
responsibility in this and the U.S
specifically the Bill Clinton
administration which gets a total clean
bill of health no one even pays
attention to what the Clinton
Administration did to them during that
period but they along with the IMF and
the World Bank absolutely destroyed
Russia and they they laid the groundwork
for a nationalistic rise of a strong man
like Vladimir Putin he probably would
have never even been the leader of
Russia but not for uh Clinton it does
seem like he's trying to hold on to save
the country that's why he won't let go
and it's like when he feels comfortable
letting go he'll just be like is that
Scott Horton's book yes yes we'll just
read uh one more time here Rife
technology says I'm fully against cbdc
but I know there's no stopping it I
already have a contract with the central
banks Ian knows who I am I've got your
Rife machine dude that's Royal rife's
grandson uh and if you don't know Royal
Rife uh he was I was experiment with
like healing the body with
electromagnetic frequency so I just
received this machine today and I'm
excited to use it so I'll use it over
the weekend and I'll get back to you and
let you know how it is all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button or
would you perhaps angrily smash that
like button and subscribe to the channel
share the show if you do like it make
sure you check out the culture War
podcast Apple Spotify and it's on
YouTube at youtube.com timcast we had
Vivek ramaswamy a two-hour conversation
we talk about a whole bunch of issues AI
the GOP Ron DeSantis his views I think
it's uh it's really interesting he made
a lot of really interesting points about
you know what AI is doing to us and
things like that as well as economic
plans and uh just you'll learn a lot a
lot about who he is he's running for
president and he's getting a lot of
traction I'm really excited to see him
on the debate stage because he he knows
so much about what's going on in the
culture War better than most people
check that out you can follow the show
at timcastirl basically anywhere but
mostly like Instagram and Facebook you
can follow me personally at timcast do
you want to shout anything out oh um I
guess you guys can follow me on Twitter
at nefertar underscore 25 you can also
watch us on oan you can Google oh and
where to watch it can help you you can
also download our app you can watch us
there live shows you can watch old
episodes
um thank you so much for having me Tim
and everyone else like I'm just super
super grateful grateful for everyone
watching very happy to be here
um so yeah thanks for coming thank you
uh Clint Russell liberty lockdown as
well as Tower gang I am just getting my
second strike lifted off of YouTube so
go subscribe to liberty lockdown on
YouTube right now I will be my very
first episode back we'll be with uh the
father of Julian Assange Gabriel so do
not miss that that's going to be on
Monday I am extraordinarily excited I I
the only other time I've cried on my
show is when I interviewed Ross
albrecht's mom and I feel like I'm gonna
I'm gonna fight and not cry during this
one so make sure you check that out and
then last but not least go to the take
human actiontour.com pick up the tickets
for uh my debate against Destiny in
Memphis two weekends from now and uh
what time is your show going live on
Monday on Liberty lock uh don't know yet
probably afternoon Monday cool that's
awesome
I'm a writer for timcast.com you should
go to at timcast or you should follow at
timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
you can go to timcast news click on the
read tab see all of our work from me our
other journalists of course Chris
Bertman is there if you want to follow
me personally you can follow me on
Instagram at Hannah claire.b and you can
follow me on Twitter at Etc thanks so
much guys bye everyone Ian Crossland and
I just wanted Karen to shout out your
Twitter again it's nefertari underscore
25 it's
nef-e-r-t-a-r-i yes underscore 25.
perfect good to see you and I also will
be at the mines Fest performing or at
least having a conversation uh this
Saturday this coming Saturday so a week
from tomorrow that's the day after our
Friday IRL show at the Vulcan theater
you can get tickets
tickets.vulcanpresents.com I think
after the timcast IRL live show on the
on Friday the Vulcan we're gonna play
music oh solid so we'll see what happens
cool but I think you know Phil will be
there you'll be there I'll be there so
maybe we'll just grab someone from the
audience who has some songs to play and
we'll just we'll go crazy cool yeah
um follow me at Kellen PDL uh Ian when
we finally get these religious shows
going Kerry you should totally come by
again because uh you know we say we
usually have fun on Fridays but this was
really this was a good one I was just
listening and it was great we should we
should do like 13 episodes of like we
call like Ian's Quest and we get like 13
different religious personalities of
different Persuasions to sit down and
explain their spirituality again can I
can I tell you how much money I would
pay to see Jordan Peterson and Ian cross
and sit down for a couple hours give me
that he knows so put it right into my
face tell me I'm just imagining Jordan
being like what no Ian listen let me say
it one more time educate me all right
we're good everybody thanks for hanging
out I got a plane to catch very early
because we're flying to Austin so uh uh
maybe I'll see you down there thanks for
hanging out we'll see you all next time